foreign
good morning and welcome along to this
long-term plan Workshop which is also
being live stream uh just once again
that
the workshop's being run in accordance
with the principles of open and
transparent decision making
it's accepted that many of us will have
our own views on quite a few matters and
in many cases we might have already had
views on what the right answer to an
issue is but um
we need to still maintain an open mind
you're not required to approach every
decision as though you've given it no
prior thought or don't have any existing
knowledge or an opinion but keeping that
open mind is is Paramount so just uh if
we keep that in mind and for those
joining on the live stream councilors
are expressing opinions or asking
questions
um but no decisions are being made and
what happens from today is it helps
formulate the documents that will come
forward to council for us to approve to
go out for consultation
so we've done the consultation that's
when the decisions are made
so we're covering off a variety of
topics today we've got
um some people from environment
Southland who are joining us this
afternoon
we're covering off the region and the
environment
and Rhiannon if you'd like to to kick us
oh sorry just before we start we do have
an apology for lateness from his worship
the mayor welcome councilor sober just a
reminder that we're live streaming uh
that's the only apology I have somebody
like to move forward
that's what sorry
apology for lightness for me clack
he's not here he's in Wellington in
business
I think well he thought he might be here
later on this morning yeah he he emailed
that he would be joining
I know he's in work
well my understanding is the next two
days he's been willing well in that case
we'll receive a defaulty
Evelyn Leslie thank you this time
Rhiannon
got our counselors so yes as um Darren
says today's discussion
Environmental
today's Workshop that will help inform
the development of asset and activity
plans and give us some direction on some
of those key environmental issues on the
agenda we've got the regional spatial
strategy and the district plan review so
um Jonathan's going to be speaking to
that updating you on
those two big pieces of work which
intersect and obviously are affected by
the RMA reform
um and then we've got an update on
climate change and the work of the
regional climate change working group
which has just commenced and steered by
environment South and India marama
um then environment surfing will be
joining after lunch so those of you
watching the lime stream there will be a
short pause while the counselors refresh
themselves and then after lunch we will
discuss the coastal plan
um latest information on New River
Estuary contaminants and the regional
public transport plan and that will be
the end of the public Workshop
so a reminder of cancel strategic
priorities and Community outcomes in the
area of the environment
um
the community outcome that's been
confirmed is a healthy resilient
environment where the city is well
positioned to navigate climate change so
that is the aim for the long-term plan
that we are in the process of developing
that we'll start on first of July 2024
and the Strategic priority for this plan
is to navigate the increasingly complex
environmental challenges including
climate change land contamination and
earthquake risks
so um I'll head back to you chair
thank you any questions about the
outline for today cool what we'll get
into as Rhiannon suggested we can look
at the regional and District planning
and that spatial plan uh Jonathan Kiara
and thank you for the gift of your
attention today so I've got two slides
today I'm keeping it deliberately high
level
um just because uh some a lot of us
don't have much time so I don't want to
get too far down into the detail I just
want to give you an overview of a couple
of work streams that we have
online at the moment and also get some
indications as to where uh you'll see
the burning issues
um first of all in the best traditional
workshops I would just like to do a very
very quick
piece of work in front of me you'll find
you've got some Post-it notes and a
pencil and I would just like you without
thinking too hard to just write down
what for you is the most pressing change
you'd like to see delivered in
invercargill it can be one word no
change is acceptable as well no
conferring it should only take about 10
seconds I'd say so you can just repeat
the question would you what's for you
what is the most pressing change you
would like to see delivered for
invercargill
so it could be one word
the sentence
you can just quickly jot it down
because it's a big difference
you mean environmental generally we'll
go with generally the study generally
yeah
sorry
so what for you is is the most pressing
change you'd like to see delivered in
invercargill
anything we'll keep we'll keep it
General yeah and I think with the slides
it'll allow you to get a bit more
specific I think it will become a bit
clearer
so whilst you do that I'll I'll speak to
the regional spatial strategy first
um and that's really part of what is the
proposed RMA reform so you'd remember
from the original Workshop I did on RMA
reform and we've had no indication that
it's slowing or it's not going ahead
we're still waiting for the last round
of submissions and to get the findings
back from those but to all intents and
purposes it's going ahead and that's our
anticipation
uh last year agreement was reached at
the mayoral forum for councils to begin
to work on a joint Regional spatial
strategy
and we we have started work on that but
again it's at a high level
um now for those of you that remember
the proposed RMA reform will feature us
having to work on joint spatial strategy
it's mandated it's anticipated with the
current time frame that those will be
delivered in a period of about five
years initially that's across the
country
um
looking at other councils who have
worked on Regional spatial strategy
Queenstown is probably the first that
Springs to mind it's taken them three
years to deliver theirs and that was not
a joint one that was on their own
uh they're an interesting case they had
some funding from central government so
we've taken that as an indicator that
the process they went through is largely
the process that would be expected
through the RMA reform
um so as I said we've started to work on
the regional spatial strategy together
and at this stage we're scoping um and
looking at the data that's going to go
into it we've had some joint meetings
um to consider what data we have
available what data would be good to
have putting that together we're
expecting to receive the results around
about mid-july that we'll be able to
share with the council in regard to
where that goes but I'm obviously having
a regional spatial strategy is really
important
um not just for the RMA reform but
actually to the region how it's going to
move forward from here
um and how we're going to resolve many
of the issues
uh so of on the slide I'll put down um
what the regional spatial strategy is
designed to achieve and I think the
biggest question here is how
invercargill sees its future the role
the city plays within the region and the
role of the region will play in the
city's future because that's something
that we want to embed into our
contribution to the regional spatial
strategy obviously different councils
will be seeking slightly different
outcomes that there is the potential
here for us to work together to
potentially resolve some of our issues
um one of them and I'm going to touch
really lightly on this because we have
another Workshop coming up but one of
them is housing
locate land that's suitable for
development and how we ensure there's
enough
um houses to house the people that we
see living here and it may be that we
have to look at other areas as supplying
some of the housing needs if we look at
the concept of commuting for example as
I say I don't really want to get too
deep into housing because that's going
to be the subject of a whole other
Workshop
um and a recent presentation that I
watched in regard to queenstown's
spatial strategy the mayor was at paying
to say a regional spatial strategy is
far more than just housing
so um I think yeah one of the questions
is definitely how how we see
invercargill moving forward from this
point in time particularly as part of
the region one of the things I notice
that where we could consider ourselves a
gateway to Southland and yeah we're at
the bottom of the region I've also noted
that
I travel from the top of the region to
work here in invercargill each day so
geographically we're spread quite away
and there's a lot of issues that that
creates for us
uh so we've done the first stage and
we're excited to have a report back to
you in July
um and then that piece of work will
identify what what further work is
required and is likely to require
significant levels of further investment
we do envisage this taking quite a while
to achieve it won't happen overnight
um one of the things that I do have in
the back of my mind is taking a cue from
Gore who we've already done some work in
the spatial planning area it could be a
consideration that we have an interim
piece of work to achieve a spatial
strategy for invercargill
I think that would allow us to have a
plan in terms of the city but also then
have that plan to be able to put that as
our contribution and further refine it
as the work progressed
and so that's one of the things I would
cover
um
so yeah I think the question really is
what key benefits does council want to
see for invercargill from a regional
spatial strategy
if it's not a rhetorical question I'll
go first
um I guess recognition of the urban
issues
um it would be very easy welcome
councilor Bond it would be very easy for
a regional strategy particularly if it's
being driven by environments Southland
to focus on environmental issues
um and even from the district's
perspective they have
um more rural issues to deal with but
the issues
that we have to deal with in an urban
setting uh very different to our
neighboring councils
any other thoughts Tom we could ask a
question first I I recall that cancel
resolved it did not want to be part of
the pilot program in this respect
um who is this different from that
so you know it's fair to say that this
would tie in with the first trunch
program
um there's there's two parts to it the
first trans program does offer central
government funding if we want to go
first on the other hand
um even if we don't participate in the
first trans program and to be clear the
details of that are still yet to be
released
um even if we weren't to participate in
the first trans program I I I could see
some real potential to creating a
regional spatial strategy it would allow
us to identify what we want and where we
want
um in a Simplicity way it's a bit like
the exercise you did at school where you
set out the zoo you couldn't have the
lines next to the Penguins because
they'd eat them we wouldn't want
industry directly next to where we were
going to develop residential so
um so I am also going back to my earlier
point if we consider housing needs what
we've identified so far through the work
and we'll be bringing more back in the
workshop is that different people have
different needs of different stages of
their lives there is the potential for
other councils to assist us with
different style housing and that's more
supported in their area than our area
I'd suggest so I can see some advantages
um as as to whether Council chooses to
be part of the first Toronto program
when eventually it's announced I I have
no particular thoughts okay so what
you're doing at the moment does not bind
us to be part of that first trance
program because it was resolved by
Council that we would not
okay okay so I mean then the answer to
the substantial question I mean what I
wrote was
um affordable housing for everyone which
means I think by building more houses
and the right type of houses
which is clearly part of the
District plan or the regional special
plan
for the urban side tell you one thing
that was never considered
heavily in in the current operative
District plan which
is one of those questions to throw out
there if there is an increased need for
housing do we need to consider an air
housing requires more intensified
housing
um and so you know is it appropriate now
for us to be considering
um apartment units and apartments closer
to town or what suburbs
um could Department living be
appropriately located in the answer is
yes
and I agree I think that that's one of
the things that's been right at the top
of my mind when we've been thinking
about housing is that there are a number
of people who provided that they had
um means of access to Upper floors would
happily live in a building that was
three or four stories high
um
but it needs to be affordable because
most of what the inner city
accommodation that is at second or third
or fourth level is beyond most people's
means so there's a balancing act in
there
can it mean if I comment on that we
they're beyond 2025
um housing paper which I don't think
many people have seen yet
um coming in a lot as the The View that
even if invercargill me actually have
enough housings they have their own kind
of houses and there is a growing body of
people who want to live in smaller homes
there's another grown body who want to
live much larger homes into generational
type homes but they're also a growing
body of people who want to live in
apartments
which probably if you asked a question
10 years ago you know there'd have been
very few people but we've been a lot of
migration a lot of those people who've
come in actually I use the apartment
living and would like the opportunity to
do that
it's just a reminder hang on you're in a
queue
um just a reminder that there is a
housing Workshop coming up in April as
well rangi thanks for waiting cheers
um
the control of uh carbon six Quest
station uh the use of land
um land is obviously valuable in our in
our area
you know and the territorial Authority
that we have and I think Council should
have some control over allowing valuable
land to be just planted and
trees so that someone can claim carbon
credits and stuff you know like I mean
it's it's like we've got the ability
obviously at sanding point with
controlled forestry and everything but
if you've got valuable land that someone
owns and they decide I'm gonna
plant it and and pinus and claim some uh
carbon points I don't think that's a
good use of land we we should be able to
have a say in how that lands use so
control over where carbon sequester yeah
yeah especially in the in like in the
our city is such a small area yeah yep
thanks Maria sorry that's okay um I was
just going to add comment to um what
evidence said about the housing so we
know that we've got an aging population
and intensifying would be
um under that consideration for
accessibility for people to have access
to main travel routes in and out of town
I think another thought that comes to my
mind is that we had environment
Southland give us a presentation about a
data collector of where's best2building
so I think we have to keep that in the
back of our mind as well we don't want
to build an error that they can predict
from their data that will be an absolute
long-term investment so I think it is
important that we do consider those
areas when we get that data
thanks
basically
thanks Chia um urban sprawl is one thing
I think we need to
address in the plan and that's one of
the reasons why we should look at
intensification and building upwards
yeah because we do have a lot of
valuable farmland and other land that
should not end up with Urban school and
it's becoming a New Zealand wider shoe
and the other thing I think we need
is some serious attention to
air rivers and
floodplains and you know we have had a
hundred year flood in 1984.
um we did some intensive work to build
stock Banks and so forth but I think if
we're going to have original spatial
strategy we need to make sure it caters
for the sort of land we should not
actually be building on the managed
Retreat that people are now talking
about more and more I think
um
in a whole Region's case it may not be
so much managed Retreat as labeling some
areas of land close to our rivers and
streams Etc is
not available for
housing use or
business use necessarily yeah thanks
Lucy that follows on from what I wrote
on my Post-It note which was managed
housing infill because we want to
maintain a balance between urban sprawl
we don't want to have to extend the
infrastructure particularly in areas
where it's pretty much a capacity if you
look at North
a stores at Northwest invercargill the
the pipes are almost full and that's yet
still where people want to to sprawl out
but with Urban infill we've still got to
make sure that we've managed the degree
of intensification so if we have lots of
those little units like you do through
the through Windsor for example where
the the sections are pretty much fully
concreted there's there's not a lot of
porous surface for rainfall to to make
its way through and that starts to
create issues as well Evelyn then ring
so very interesting you say that Mr
chair because that was one of the points
that I was going to make
um the the hardening off of so much of
our surfaces is one of the issues that
is intensifying the effect of
um very Swift runoff and and Rain events
um it was interesting to see
um in the Auckland event where there was
a community that was designed with a
great deal of
ability for water permeability in terms
of wetlands and places that were
intentionally left for that purpose
um so given that we have some land that
is
um
list an Optimum for housing and for
other sorts of activities whether we
should be looking at actually allowing
fans to to be created or intentionally
create them to cater for
those sorts of things but also how we
address what is it permitted under
um
a building consent in terms of how much
of that section is actually hardened off
and I know people want to have a place
to park their vehicles but when we're
seeing four
you know the parking being created for
four buildings uh vehicles but there's
also a garage and all the rest of it
deliberately creating the capacity to
park cars or boats or whatever but it
it's great for the people that own the
houses it's not great for the
environment where is the balance in
there and what can we influence in those
conversations ring
um just getting a gauge on the
conversation with um Enfield versus
Outfield now I just want to sort of get
get a get a feeling of how the what this
Council thinks about the new development
down Rockdale Road treadmill Road I mean
obviously 600 odd sections uh the land
was not really used for for much and to
me I think that's you know creates a
nice new community and everything but
with that sort of thing in the future be
frowned upon or is it going to be Case
by case or you know it's a case by case
so going through being a part of the
plan change
for that area one of the things that
worked in its favor was that it's it's
not hugely intensified so there's still
a small degree of property there's a lot
of amenity that's worked into the the
planning and there was also capacity in
the infrastructure so so that leads to
an X question when we do create this
30-year spatial plan
there's a clause there case by case
because that's basically what we do we
have to leave the door all planning is
like that I know but that's what I mean
it's very hard to create a plan
but it's not really a plan because the
case by case thing creeps up someone
comes up with a new idea we've got the
the one just to the north of the other
golf course there at outer Tara that's
going to be quite a few sections each
each person with a hunk of land will
come to council and say I've got a case
that this is a this is a great idea
and and obviously the whole Resource
Management act kicks in and then we have
debates and everything so the plan
really goes out the door because if we
have a case-by-case basis
um why have a plan so the plan provides
a mixture of guidelines and rules rules
are the hard and fast stuff guidelines
are indications of of what's preferable
you wouldn't for example build
residential house next to a heavy
industrial Zone oh yeah no no I
understand that but I just you're
looking at this outlying land like that
case I just talked about down Rockdale
Road now you know that's a good use for
it I I absolutely agree but there's lots
of examples if we look around the
perimeter of invercargill way that could
happen yep so partially that was
identified in the current District plan
and that was based around the areas
where we would prefer to see development
happen where it's easier
um and and a lot of that was based on
available land and capacitive
infrastructure so it's the same process
so if you tag it Case by case but
infrastructure dependent yeah I mean the
infrastructure is the keyboard in there
yep Tom yeah uh a really critical issue
to the decide who you're going to treat
it right from the beginning is what we
assume the population is going to be in
you know five ten years 15 years time
and you know we I think we all know that
a critical mistake that was made back in
you know maybe 20 years ago
was that the stats people were
forecasting that by this time uh
invercargill's population would have
fallen to thirty thousand and of course
denial you know climb back up again and
and uh as a win again we see those
housing statistics come out there is a
forecast going forward again
invercargill's population will fall in
the 2030s quite significantly that's it
so if you assume that then we're going
to end up Frozen at the spot again I
think as far as so uh and there's
another argument that says you know
maybe it's a consequence of climate
change and issues up north it may be far
more people want to come
11 invercargill so we could see that a
verse we could see a significant
population increase so it's difficulty
plan unless you have a I mean you either
plan for a a given population or else
you do I think you know councilor Putin
just saying and that is that you you
could have a lot of flexibility in that
plan because you've got to be able to
respond to change circumstances so I'm
just going to pause I see your tradition
I'll hold on for a second because we're
dropping down into the district plan
which I think is the next slide you've
got Jonathan
let's do it
okay um so this this one deals with the
district plan
um so icc's District plan was enacted in
um
a few um bits that I've drawn out of
there
um so as part uh under the RMA we're
required to more or less continually
review our district plan
um to check that it is effective it's
delivering the required outcomes
and to see if we can have any
efficiencies
we did carry out an initial plan effect
on this report in 2021 which identified
that further work was required in
particular it was an assessment of
housing capacity
um and also had climate change will
influence and shape invercargill so both
pieces of work are underway it's fair to
say that over it hasn't been quite as
quick as we'd like we've been a little
bit under-resourced in the policy area
for planning but we are starting to pick
it up
um and I think in some ways I see the
district planners going somewhat hand in
hand with the regional spatial strategy
what I've taken from listening to the
comments is that a regional spatial
strategy would require sufficient
flexibility to adapt to the changes that
we could could reasonably foresee and
also something we couldn't foresee over
such a period likewise with the district
plan it's like it's a relatively recent
plan it was enacted in 2019 so we're now
four years in
um and the question is where to with the
district playing from here one of the
considerations is that
if we're going to go through RMA reform
and we're going to change and have a
regional planning committee and a
regional plan
um the question is what do we need to do
for the here and now in terms of the
district plan anticipating that in the
future it will go and I should put the
caveat in that indications with the RMA
reform currently are that we could
potentially be working on Regional
spatial strategy and District plan at
the same time and that will then raise a
question about where we deploy our
resources to
I know that when dealing with the
district plan it's quite quick to it can
be an easy fix to challenge it and say
that it just doesn't work to deliver
um what I would say is uh in terms of
District plan
if we look at the
um if we look at the building side and
one of the things I think invercargill
City can be really proud of is that we
currently have one of the best
performing building consent authorities
in the country that wasn't the case a
few years ago
um
the changes that we made were around how
we approached the building consenting
side of things and also how we
approached the code we didn't change the
code
and one of the things I'm really
interested in is how much we could
change our approach with a district plan
to get some efficiencies before we go
into the Avenue exploring it one of the
reasons for that is that sometimes we go
into things with the best of intentions
um with an outcome in mind but through
the process of collaboration and it can
change into something else and we also
have the unanticipated consequences of
our actions I think a good example where
we could change our approach slightly
would be it's not uncommon for people to
on larger blocks of land where they're
building a bigger home initially they'll
put up a smaller one as I shed the to
all intents and purposes allows them to
live in whilst they're building it
my usual approach was then to insist
that they made sure they couldn't reside
in that smaller property once they'd
finished the big one to the point that
we'd potentially ask them to remove a
kitchen say I'd suggest that we probably
don't want to continue that approach
we'd like to work with people and I
think in the spirit of inject injecting
some trust into the relationship
we would advise them that you can't have
two on one lot so it needs to be used
together and so that to me is a quick
efficiency with the district plan that
could address an issue so what I'm
really Keen to hear about is
how we see the deficiencies with the
district plan if there are any so what
changes do we want if any and how um
it's it can be a bit of a labor process
if we want to do some fairly significant
changes we need to scope them and then
take them out for consultation before
implementing them so I I think what I'm
trying to say is that with the RMA
reform coming I just sound a motor
caution about
um really going Whole Hog with the
district plan at this stage but I'm
certainly Keen to investigate it it's I
mean it's ludicrous to do a full
District playing review while the
spatial plan is being consulted on but
the beauty of the way the new District
plans are constructed is you can do them
piece by piece you don't have to go
through an entire review and I guess one
of the things that has served us well in
the the last
the 18 months is the fact that we've
been
customer focused from that building
consenting perspective and if we're able
to
employ the same practices as much as we
can in resource consenting rather than
building consenting as well
um particularly in around I think
minimum lot size and there was an
example of good Urban Design might have
been housing Corporation or some some
organization that went below the minimum
permitted lot size but actually through
their design develop good amenity so you
weren't you know walking straight into
your neighbor's back door as you left
there was a degree of privacy and being
able to Stamp Those in in different
places should be an easy process where
you see something that's been permitted
that works making that easy to be
replicated and I think the other thing
we need to bear in mind not that it's
not permitted is how do we address the
issue of tiny houses
when we had the presentation from the
gentleman in about 18 months ago
um when we pointed out that tiny houses
are possible but how do we exercise some
control around those Trish thank you for
waiting so it's probably a little bit
too much detail but one of the things
that is really important I think is that
we consider our aging population some of
our older houses and a community so you
know if we can get to the position where
we can get perhaps older people or some
people out of those big houses and Recon
re-convert the land to more on the same
thing they have a community we need to
make sure they've got transport options
but I think we can if we that's that
intensification of land has to include
that aspect as well
oh sorry
yeah I hear what you're saying trash but
I'm just going back to two two bits of
Housing Development that I was fortunate
to actually look at and one was the
naitahu development in Canterbury
Christchurch there where the houses are
far too close together and the roofs
actually nearly touch and there is no
sort of
leg room in any way form the other
a lot of housing on learnings was in
tighter in Wellington where they did
this whole bit of Community Development
the cap you know the council judge and
they failed to put any sort of car
parking facility
with those those apartments and sadly
the streets and they showed me was like
and the neighbors just cringe because
there's no movement on the street
because all these cars are packed
along the streets and no one can get in
and out of the housing because of it so
these learnings
my brother has a house in Wellington on
a narrow street that they could not get
a fire engine to when it was needed
so if we are going to consider anything
in development whether it's apartment or
or how uh you know um
shared type Arrangements where you need
to consider where there's a parking
space
thanks Evelyn
so thinking back to the issue about
the small blocks the the one hectare one
house type thing
when we know that there's now increasing
pressure for people to have
multi-generational living opportunities
but having some sort of a lifestyle
opportunity as well
should they be mutually exclusive
um I understand what you're saying
Jonathan about the first you know
because it has been an issue over the
years the first property
um being a sort of a semi garage type
thing with a
enough facilities for people to camp for
a period of time or they built having to
be decommissioned
should we really
be saying to people
if it's going to be occupied by a family
member
like up here and a grandparent that sort
of thing that it's permissible but
mustn't be used for rentals or things
like that is that something that we're
looking at because rentals would
obviously detract from that
um
lifestyle
can't vibe that they were originally
intended to be but still be flexible
enough to accommodate what people
some some families like mine would
really like to be the ideal where when
as you age you don't have to move off
the property you just move into a
different part of the property and it's
able to be accommodated is that one of
the things that you're raising when you
mentioned that so what I was trying to
do is to say that we could potentially
get some efficiencies that is the
current situation you can have two on
one lot if it's being used by the family
obviously there's a concern that over
time something could develop whereby the
property changed hands and does somehow
end up on the rental market which is not
what we want currently but it's a case
to my mind it's a case of explaining to
the owner what their responsibilities
are and actually putting the trust back
into the relationship and I see that as
an efficiency we can get the current
District plan so that was just one
example of how how by adjusting our
approach to the current District plan we
can get some small wins
I want to park housing and save the rest
of it for the housing Workshop there's a
couple of things from a district plan
perspective that have come up that are
really useful I guess something I want
to Signal Jonathan is business zones
um and and Retail activity so we've gone
and invested a lot of money as a city in
building
the Central City Hub
and wanting to place I guess tighter
controls on what sort of retail activity
can sprawl further out uh from that Hub
it should be easier for people to to set
up in here rather than apart from
residential the nodes of like Windsor or
South City or Glengarry
um but also we probably need to be aware
of of Home occupations
um particularly those that have an
effect on neighbors now there's a
difference between someone who might be
running a hair salon from their home and
and that's permitted because they don't
employ more than a couple of people but
they are getting away cleverly with
cheaper rates
um or people who run their offices from
homes but there are also people who
become panel beating businesses which is
not something that should be happening
in a residential area so tightening up
on on some of those home occupations and
residential zones something we'd need to
look at
ring and then Tom
um
funny you should raise that I mean
obviously I'm just thinking about
certain developments that you know went
through the resource management act to
get established in invercargill
and you take a take a say a garden
center that requires quite a bit of land
um you if you want to set up one of
those you're going to struggle to find
land in our in our zones you need to be
almost going semi-rural or to find some
space and there's a lot of businesses
like that
uh
that I don't think you can stop you know
again it must be Case by case if they've
got a if they're environmental impact is
okay they're providing it's the amenity
value is good it's not looking terrible
so I think creating these strict
industrial areas or business areas it's
a bit it's a bit tough
um just until someone sits up next to
your house no no but I'm saying like an
example of that so you don't put
a nursery don't put a nickels or a dyax
I mean where are they going to find the
land
you know I mean they they're gonna find
uh some well so in those examples you've
just got to worry about traffic impact
actually because they're low noise yeah
there's not a lot of noise there but
there's a lot of traffic coming and
going I guess as long as there's there's
good traffic routes and you know you can
get onto and off the roads easily that
it shouldn't be an issue but you're
right it's about finding where where
that is like say you have a Bunnings
came to town you know where would they
don't we have one
now we've got the commercial one yeah we
haven't got the the retail one so you
know where they sort of find a massive
area
uh yeah
yeah Tom
it's changing the subject a little bit
obviously into faces with housing but we
we do need I think this part of you know
working the next short number of years
to be having a plan that deals with
issue of adaptation to climate change
and where must we consider managed
Retreat
um where are we able to protect the city
just through you know various means and
I know that we are going to talk about
that maybe this afternoon we get
probably more time now to do it but
um you know that an awful lot of that
goes to the data that we have which is
inadequate at the moment like in lead
our data and precise Heights and so
forth
but uh but I think you know part in the
next plan we have is gonna have to be I
think
um maybe not you know precise decisions
but but certainly these are the areas
which if there's a meter rise in sea
level we simply kind of protect here are
areas where we believe we can't protect
it may take a 30 years to develop the
protection but we believe we are going
to be able to protect it I think those
sort of decisions are going to have to
be taken um in the next few years which
probably means you know in line with the
development of this plan
excellent timing time because it's a
beautiful segue
from District planning Into Climate
Change before we get into the matter in
Greater detail when environment South
and get here sorry Barry was there
something you want to do yeah
um I've been concerned for a long time
about the old wrex at uh especially in
Bay Road and Industrial land yeah
what about all the leakage that comes
off those Vehicles so I understand
that's under investigation
good point though I mean it's a visual
eyesore and everybody gets that but it's
in an appropriately zoned area so I know
that our staff and environment South
under are looking at what's the
potential on the water plane in that
area
thanks Jonathan if I may before I go
um if if you could just take the time to
decide if you're happy with the answer
you've got on your Post-it though if
you're not please feel free to change it
I would love to collect them in um and
just use them as a pointer for the
further bit of work I need to do thanks
Jonathan I'll collect them in at lunch
so Brandon
yes so excellent
um segue from the deputy mayor there who
is council's representative on the
regional working group along with
councilor Leslie cyper so you may both
have things that you want to add in
comments
um we have a few slides myself and Leo
so Leo I just want to come forward maybe
until at the table there
um we're just going to run through a
little bit of a summary you'll have also
received the
um paper that's in the council agenda
for this meeting with an update on our
approach to climate change
um so Council has been working on this
issue in an establishary kind of phase
for a while now in the existing
long-term plan there are a number of
focus areas that are laid out and the
officers have been working to improve
the knowledge and data that we have
across the issue of climate change to
put us in a better position to support
you making decisions going forward
um so the first Focus area is to
understand first and manage council's
own climate impact so understanding the
impact of Cancer's activities on carbon
and other greenhouse gas emissions and
Leo's going to talk more about that in a
moment
um secondly to understand and manage
risk to our key Council infrastructure
then particularly firstly those parts of
the infrastructure that are essential to
life and water infrastructure roading
Etc
and thirdly to support Regional work to
set a climate strategy for the city as
part of a waijo regional strategy so
it's great to see that the regional
climate change working group has been
established Now by environment Southland
until marama and we are involved in and
supporting that piece of work in the
meantime council's been looking at its
own activities and making sure that we
are in the best position possible on the
issue of climate change obviously
climate change is a very complex issue
there are still a lot of uncertainties
and unknowns in terms of how it is going
to impact on the region and when
um so I've outlined here on the slides
and proposed principles really for your
consideration as we approach this issue
one has already been mentioned and that
is a data LED approach so we'll give a
bit more of a detail in a moment about
where the knowledge on climate change
for the region sits
um but it is really important to make
sure that we understand
what the issues are that the region
faces and when those are likely to
arrive and we don't yet have all the
data that we need in order to be able to
do that
um that we think that it's sensible to
take a regional approach which considers
risks and opportunities
um there are some opportunities
potentially for the region from changing
climate patterns in terms of new
business opportunities crops Etc that
may be available although of course the
risk profile is the one that has been
considered more to this point and
remains considerable So within the
existing long-term plan we have based
our climate change assumptions on the
2018 newer study that looked at the
impacts of climate change within
Southland we have used the mid-range
forecasts and those
um
those uh sorry that's distracting me
slightly those
um mid-range forecasts relate to
primarily the risks of increasingly
intense High rainfall events and the
risks of flooding that come with that
and the risks of high temperature
increasing periods of high temperature
and what that might mean for Drought
um and also the impact of sea level rise
on low-lying areas
so those are already built into the
assumptions that council is operating on
it's particularly relevant in areas like
um in the Engineering Services team and
the types and sizes of pipes that they
put into
um replace infrastructure that's Aging
in the city
also propose taking a holistic policy
making and risk assessment approach
climate change can't be considered on
its own policies that will interact and
affect climate change will have
significant costs attached there are
high levels of uncertainty in many areas
and so it's really important to consider
a way up as you will do in all of the
issues that you're facing in long-term
planning how you manage those kind of
cost issues and balance issues and risks
against
other factors in the long-term planning
and then we've focused on the regional
strategy in the district plan and so
having a a sense of
where we are going as a region but
keeping within council's control clear
targets and activities so those are some
proposed principles as we approach this
issue of climate change
um so this next slide shows the work
structure for the regional working group
um the exact structure of what the
strategy is that comes out of this
working group is still to be formed
there's been one meeting so far this is
the framework that environment certain
in town with the support of the other
councils is putting forward in terms of
an approach
it really focuses on two issues of
adaptation and Emissions reduction
it looks at firstly what needs to happen
where is there an interagency approach
and where is it relevant for councils to
continue to move and act on their own
we're very cognizant of the fact that we
can't wait for the regional strategy we
need to be moving as well and looking at
what council's responsibilities are and
that has been set up through the
existing long-term plan and then there
is the opportunity to consult the
community on the strategy as part of
each council's long-term planning
consultation process
so um we as a council have been already
doing things in the space of adaptation
and Emissions reduction Leo is going to
run through some of those aspects
um
now
good morning Mr chair good morning
everybody else my name is Leo I'm the
Lesser member of the policy team and uh
here to take you to the wonderful Maze
of climate change action policy
um so as you know effectively any
element of climate change action has two
Wings to this bed well of course
adaptation and the other one is
mitigation the mitigation policy and the
mitigation aspect is effectively about
reducing the amount of greenhouse gas
that we emit into the atmosphere as well
as decarbonizing the atmosphere taking
it out of it and of course the
adaptation is really about producing a
degree of physical economic demographic
and biosecurity resilience to
detrimental effects of climate change
so uh in the first wings so to speak
about the mitigation which is really
about emission reduction before we go
into that one just one point is that
there is some legislative framework
around this element there is a carbon
response Act and the carbon response act
Amendment the zero carbon that
effectively leads the central government
to attach itself to the Target of
achieving a Net Zero by 2050
some may consider that at this stage
given of course How Far We've Come not
uh probably not as realistic or as
achievable as initially was expected but
of course his policy and this
legislation is dynamic uh in terms of
progressing the emission reduction and
engaging in mitigation policy the first
step the first critical step is always
setting the carbon Baseline uh we have
effectively done this for the last
Financial year it has yielded the result
which is not entirely surprising for an
organization of this size and there's no
great anomaly it's 50 15 590 ton of uh
greenhouse gas it's not just CO2 it is
CO2 equivalent so they all kind of lump
it into one for the Simplicity of
analysis uh the sources of emission are
again
there's no great anomaly here there are
either by
direct action of Council in this case
the primary source being the treatment
the operation of treatment of Wastewater
plants and followed by indirect emission
by purchase electricity purchased
powerful for transportation as well as
procurement of goods and services
so this is basically what we have done
so far uh this Baseline allows us to
measure our progression within in the
future as we move on to uh reduce our
emission by the by any means and
mechanism that is available to us so
this is a critical part many effectively
Tas in New Zealand have not taken this
particular step so we have done
effectively quite Progressive in this
Regard in terms of the steps we have to
take to reduce the emission as well as
taking that embedded carbon from the
atmosphere as you can see on the right
side we have taken some steps uh those
examples are quite interesting the
boiler in the splash Palace have moved
from the lignite to wood chip and the
hybrid vehicle transition of the general
Council vehicle fleet has started uh all
the electric all the maintenance
Machinery in the Parks have effectively
moved from uh moved from carbon from
fossil fuel to electricity and thirty
thousand thirty three thousand building
property it documents have been
digitized or in the process of
digitization as well as of course uh
this being the norm now we have tried to
establish attending in corporate
meetings through uh video conferencing
softwares which effectively cut down on
the prospect of commuting all the way
and the tree planting measure which is
truly about uh planting a tree for every
resident of the city so you can see
overall and also in comparison to the
Tas across the country our actions in
this wing of emission reduction has been
significant
and I guess uh one question for us to
consider here is that uh
whether we wish to achieve that Net Zero
states by 2050 or any other kind of a
time frame we wish to attach ourselves
to and of course the second question
would be where is the scope and the
limitation of our ambition is it
something that we only if we decide to
go down that path of achieving true Net
Zero that would be our mission would
effectively be neutralized by the other
measures actually we've taken to offset
that emission just for this organization
or do we intend to expand it to the
wider community
in by any degree that we can achieve so
that's the first question that we wish
to gain some guidance from this body
Tom then ringing in Evelyn
um chair obviously you know this is a
subject that I've been quite a lot
involved in and I I'm actually
encouraged that you know when I look at
the size of the issue I mean you know
global climate change is a massive issue
but if we look at the effect in
invercargill to me it's manageable if we
start new but if we if we talk just
about mitigation for a minute and we we
produce about 15 000 tons of carbon
dioxide a year
um now that is ICC that is not city and
we have at some point to understand what
the city makes but ICC
um 15 000.
um if we were to aim for Net Zero
um let's suppose we could buy all of the
programs that we are already undertaking
if we could reduce that by half let's
just suppose which I think is entirely
reasonable
um than to buy officers to bicarbon
offsets uh it would cost us about half a
million dollars a year to offset the
remaining seven and a half thousand or
so half a half a million dollars a year
if we were decided to do it through
planting it would be about 500 hectares
we planted 500 hectares of near the
forest on unproductive land it would
offset the balance of
um the uh the carbon that that we emit
so that seems to me as a challenge it's
more akin to climbing Bluff Hill and it
is to climb in Mount Everest I mean it's
perfectly doable it seems to me so I I
think if we set a maintenance and and
you know it would be quite possible for
us to commit to Net Zero as ICC was in a
reasonably
um short period actually certainly
medium term period I'll leave it at that
I've got other comments about adaptation
but let's let's just we're talking about
mitigation at the moment thanks Tom
appreciate that ring it thanks chair
look
um I'm pleased to actually raised this
because it was coming up this afternoon
I'm just pondering electricity now
our electricity comes from Hydro I'm
just wondering where where you get this
cabin emission what's can you tell me
the calculations behind
the production of hydroelectricity or
wind electricity
why it's up there uh I guess I can
answer this question in the context of a
wider consideration regarding some of
these assessments and the first point to
consider here I'm just asking the
science behind it yes so first of all is
that these projections are either true
what we call Raw data that they actually
do have say for example somebody who's
producing electricity or producing
emission through exhaustion of engines
and all that they do have uh effectively
technological equipment that can measure
that quite quite clearly on at their end
and of course electricity is something
that has been produced indirectly by us
indirectly by us and of course the
patches from somebody else in the report
the quality of the data associated with
electricity has been considered quite
High indicating that the producer of
that electricity has measured that
information by Technical and
technological means very very accurately
between 90 to 100 accuracy the way they
can do that uh I guess one of the ways
they they can this is by implementing
certain monitoring softwares that can
effectively create an equivalence
between every unit of electricity use
and every unit of greenhouse gas that
actually may have been produced or has
been produced through the process
um
in terms of the report projection and of
course how they have how they have
produced this it seems to indicate
because of the data quality associated
with that particular one projection of
electricity is that uh
highly accurate uh technological
instruments have been used to measure
that gig emission that greenhouse gas
emission produced by that but the report
is silent on this in itself well just
look at the Clyde dam for example we've
got what are falling through gravity
spinning turbines
electricity is projects comes down power
line goes into a lot of Transformers and
gets to us now I'm really struggling
really struggling to believe that
there's any emission in that process and
that's why I'm asking you please explain
the science because you've got a very
high number up there 12.5 every time we
turn the light switch on we're creating
a mission you know like it just you know
um it's really hard to I mean I want to
come on board with this but when you put
something like that up there I'm going
this is uh
yeah this is weird Tom perhaps you can
help out with that I think I know the
answer to that one actually right here
obliged to use the grid Factor when you
calculate your emissions which means
that if say 17 of New Zealand's
electricity is produced from fossil
fuels you're obliged to count that in
your
um in your calculation make any
difference where your own electricity
comes from no no no but no that that
should be the key you've got to be
joking to the fact that so we're we're
factoring in the Huntley power station
into our electricity use well that's how
it's done but actually sometimes we are
actually getting perfect monthly per
station you got to remember that in dry
years and so forth we do actually import
to the South Island
electricity made from fossil fuels this
at 12.5 is incredibly High yeah but that
that's just so weird it's just the way
it's done you know doesn't make any
difference if you you could be hooked up
to a hydro station you're still required
to use the the grid fighter okay have a
look
yeah I was going to say it costs you
create
um
these are fixed by even the hardware
that you need to run these things
everything that you manufacture creates
um greenhouse gas because anyway that
was not really the point I think that
I'm pleased that we're discussing it on
plays that we're looking at it from what
the council can do I think one of the
things that as well as getting our own
house in order is the messages that we
send to the community one of the things
I believe firmly believe that we're here
to be as Leaders as leaders and thought
leaders and action leaders so if we are
encouraging
activities that reduce
carbon for example planting natives at
Sandy Point where once always was
natives so it's not that they won't grow
there it's we've chosen to grow finest
there because it's been a a revenue
generation activity for the council we
might talk about how good a revenue
generator it was but it has been a
revenue generator or seen to be that if
we plant natives there
because of their long life span they
offset
those carbon you know the the greenhouse
gases for a much longer period of time
plus which they actually add some
stability and
um a trait night of foods and things
like that which is something that adds
to our enjoyment of the place
I think we've got to actually encourage
people to think that the one tree they
plant in their future that is not going
to be harvested
but it's going to grow shelter and add
to the
um the environment also contributes to
the reduction of greenhouse gas the
little things we do not just the big
things we do and that if we send those
messages by what we do as well
but encouraging people to make change
being an influence a positive influence
for this matter so thanks Leo I think
that's a firm maybe you know it's a it's
a good aspirational thing and let's get
information to to help flesh out and
work towards our moving on ringing
because there's another question
and that was
um do we look at internal contestable
funds do you want to flesh that out for
us later
so yeah I'll speak to this so um
you will notice when you get reports
from Council managers that they talk
about the climate change implications in
those reports many of the low-hanging
fruit as you can see to the right hand
side has been picked in terms of areas
where it is easier to reduce our carbon
emission that doesn't mean that there
aren't further easier opportunities but
we are getting towards the point where
difficult investment decisions will be
made there are a number of ways of doing
this
um it can be just built into the
activity planning when they put it
Forward they'll say here are your
options counselors this one is cheaper
but it's not going to achieve your
carbon outcome therefore we recommend
this more expensive option
that requires a level of maturity that
in terms of being able to assess carbon
impact that we as a council I would say
we are not there yet and many and most
councils in New Zealand are not yet
there because it takes a lot of work to
be able to fully assess what the carbon
impact therefore one way that councils
have been supporting action is by having
an internal internal contestable fund
where different teams within the
organization can say we want to do this
project and they can shape it up as a
project that doesn't then need to align
as closely with planning cycles and they
can apply for funding this is really
just an opportunity for you to start to
think about
your kind of a preferred approach and
then we can bring that back in later in
the ltp process when we get to budgeting
towards the end of the year can you tell
me with the other councils that have
used that has that inspired innovation
yes it has inspired innovation in some
areas
um like many of these things there's
been challenges also so Council it has
been primarily larger councils that are
really progressing on this type of thing
things Wellington Auckland
would be further along
um than many of the smaller councils
because this is a challenge challenging
issue to address
Tom
hey
jealous approach
um but it's essential when we when we
did our exercise that we are considering
offsets as well
because
um the whole point of carbon
charges is to make sure that
economically the money goes to the right
projects
so there's no point in to save you know
a ton of carbon you spend a million
dollars it makes no sense at all you'd
be better to spend the seventy dollars
and buy this ton of carbon so I I think
offsets are going to be considered
particularly
um you know planting as an alternative
which is often much cheaper than
actually buying a very expensive Gizmo
that you know that so I I'd support the
approach provided it built-in analysis
as that question of offset
thanks Tom
ringing
um just looking at the right hand column
there and considering Solutions do we
have to and Evelyn touched on it before
do we have to consider the carbon
footprint of the solution so let's try
hybrid vehicles and do we have to take
an account
let's say it came from China they used
which is mainly coal-fired electricity
and where the lithium came from
everything like that do we have to take
that into account or do we park that and
and just say look
we got this feel-good Factor about
buying a hybrid vehicle forget about how
it's made we don't want to know that so
we have to do that for any solution we
find
look at the carbon footprint of the
solution
absolutely it should be assessed in the
decision making and that's where I don't
see it up there that's all that's where
I'm making reference to the maturity
like that's a complicated thing to do
and it's not straightforward so um
that is why many councils are taking an
alternative route because it takes time
to build up the knowledge within the
organization so if we done that for our
I see our electric vehicles no car park
no there's been a cost benefit
assessment that has been easier to do
because essentially there hasn't been a
great cost
decision involved it's been that's what
I mean when these are some of the more
easy decisions to make because there are
Financial benefits as well
um it is going to get more complicated
and difficult from here on out so you
are raising very valid points and I'm
just being completely open about the
maturity of the organization to be able
to fully assess those decisions we are
not there yet most organizations around
the New Zealand are not there yet
okay let's Jump Ahead to the subject
that Tom touched on before so I'm
interested to hear what you've got to
say uh first of all introduce the slide
around adaptation
right
um so adaptation effectively really got
the long and short of it this is all
about the accuracy of data so uh we uh
the previous slides back we just talked
about the state of the data available to
us in this region effectively this is as
it stands it's a fairly high cut as a
high level data in which of course we
have a general high-level understanding
of the impacts of climate change on uh
in terms of especially sea level rise as
well as the recurrence of uh of flooding
events and and heavy rain but uh
predominantly this is based on the 2018
niwai studies the newer studies in the
lack of lidar which is the highest
resolution of course data you can
possibly get relies on a less accurate
set of data predominantly being the uh
the first generation of
um
digital elevation models which is as
accurate as four to five meters well of
course lidar is far more accurate than
to impact several centimeters so
in terms of adaptation effectively this
whole thing is all about the marriage of
three concepts one is What scenario is
actually going to occur in terms of the
sea level rise in terms of the in terms
of the flooding events Coastal erosion
and all that sort of stuff so
that is one point of determination which
of course uh effectively
um nivo has taken somehow between uh two
scenarios that are considered to be the
most likely and of course projected a
certain level of sea level rise within
the midterm 2045 and long term to 2090.
uh this particular assumption this
assertion about what of course is sea
level rise is going to be is going to
effectively determine the type of the
coastal erosion Coastal Foundation uh
salt intrusion is going to occur on the
other side uh the assumption is also
going to shape that if the recurrence of
flooding events the amount of the heavy
rainfall is going to of course occur and
that of course is a second part of this
of this critical assumption that has
been shaped so in that sense when you
look at the Neo's report it does provide
a high quality a high level data about
General assumptions regarding effects of
climate change in the region but it is
not as accurate as a lidar modeling that
can possibly provide because lidar is
far more accurate in terms of
determining the Topography of a region
that is going to respond to be subjected
to the effects of sea level rise and
riverine flooding uh so in that sense
um
regardless of course of uh regardless of
the completion of lidar which of course
is still ongoing Council has effectively
responded to even those high-level
assumptions by especially responding to
uh the possibility of the sea level rise
as was projected for example at a
project in the street in the city street
uh uh flood bank is one response to that
at the increase in the specifications of
uh of the storm water pipes is a
response to the prospect of of heavier
flooding as well as a few other projects
that are effectively manifestations of
council's response to neva's mid-range
assumptions about the effects of climate
change as reflected through its
infrastructural planning but
if I can use a military term here it's
uh
coming from a military background myself
this is a very good and at metaphor
if you have infinite amount of uh
ammunition you can effectively just use
it complete liberality
but when the resources and ammunition is
in fact finite then you require as
accurate as data you can possibly get to
inform your investment and planning
decision making so in in that particular
sense as of course the report that we
have uh that we commissioned from Tonkin
and Taylor it effectively comes to
reinforce assumptions that of course the
newer report produced but provided us
with a very clear view for the critical
need for as accurate information we can
possibly get to show us uh the true
impact of the climate change scenarios
on Coastal erosion on salt intrusion on
Coastal organization and river and
flooding without that data without that
clear data investment and planning
decision making will have to be high
level
with that data then you would exactly
know what to do and where to do and that
information can effectively feed into
complex modeling process which can tell
us quite exactly quite precisely where
for example a stock bank has to be
developed where a new type of an
approach or new engineering design have
to be implemented for certain stormwater
designs whereas where are the flood
planes and the flood banks are going to
be so uh
it's an interesting question I guess
about the Estuary which is a highly
complex environment because it is a
concentration of a variety of factors
that can effectively be fundamentally
influenced by climate change that
particular history is a good example as
I said of why lidar is effectively
needed uh
the Duncan and Taylor's report
repeatedly focus on the fact that this
information is essential this report
which of course we have initially
commissioned to show us the impact of
climate change the negative impact of
climate change and our critical
infrastructure effectively evolved to be
a gap analysis that they told us well we
don't have this information you do need
to like you you do need a lidar to be
able to mature this information so we
exactly come to know what are going to
be the effects these adverse effects on
critical infrastructure so uh
one question of course here is that this
slider information is supposed to be
available sometimes between the end of
2023 and some and early 2024 but one
question as well has been raised there
is what is the appetite of this body for
uh
um a more Regional approach and a more
Regional collaboration for the
development and accumulation of a high
resolution data
it's uh as I said this is a critical
Factor your planning is going to be as
effective as accurate data you're going
to build built it upon
synopsis makes good sense because it's
going to essentially help inform the
stuff that we're going to need to do for
a district plan and also for the
regional strategy Tom yeah
so uh I mean I support what's been said
um the steadstreet project was
absolutely the right thing you're doing
and it was bleeding obvious that it
needed to be done
as you go beyond that I think we we have
to fight the temptation to just sort of
go on and do stuff because we feel
there's a sense of urgency you know we
need to do the right stuff and and I
think the right thing you do is going to
become more obvious when we get lidar
data and we can do the
um the analysis on that if you don't
quite get it right it's very very easy
to get it horribly wrong and I mean I'll
put comes out in my mind as a you know
the famous Calvary Dam
project for the you know they built up
and then tension or drain in the river
so that they could pick up the gold
um unfortunately got the height slightly
wrong and the water flowed backwards and
it never actually and that was just a
matter of getting Heights slightly wrong
in it and in reality is that the systems
that we aren't using now to determine
the precise relative Heights there's not
that much more sophisticated than it was
back then so I think we we really need
to delayed our data that work is ongoing
um and then I think once we have that we
we have to be part of a process which
um certainly is going to be done
regionally I'm getting a date which
allows us to determine what needs to be
what are the right things today to
protect the city and protect Bluff and
to protect those other parts of the
um of this area that we that we need to
and you know personally I think it's all
doable as long as we prove it as long as
we again Do the Right Stuff
Leo with your commentary that you've
just um touch on with the slide
um you've pointed out that the lighter
data is quite essential I guess
um
I mean I'm all for improving what we're
doing in order to protect our
environment and climate my question and
concern is about the quantitative
outcome to different scientific data to
different organizations so how do we
quantify that that we're not going to
find ourselves in a contradiction
contradiction in the future to a
different scientific data telling
different information what are we
expected to do in terms of
um if we have leader or another
organization
um and that data is completely
completely opposite to what the other is
telling us
um what would be well I guess it depends
on uh
um what do we mean by contradictory data
are you referring to the fact that the
lidar May in fact yield results that is
contradictory to our current assumptions
um actually I don't think that was what
Rhea was suggesting I think she was
asking what about organizations using
different reporters yeah and they're in
the answers
yeah you're right that's one point but
there was also my second point was about
the inconsistency
well I guess once we have the most
accurate kind of a data then uh that
will have to become effectively the
primary point of reference well one
thing about again of course by the
lighter we have to really kind of take
into account it's that current planning
seems to be residing on the digital
elevation models as well as the existing
vertical land movements so we have these
two offsetting kind of factors that move
around to show right where the sea level
rise is going to be this one and then
for example we have also the vertical
land movement as well as a contour so
this existing data of course as you
mentioned has come to form many uh many
decision-making bases
the lidar is probably going more likely
to be to refine that I'm I'm not an
expert I guess on the line of data it's
an interesting question whether of
course a lighter high resolution thing
is going to contradict it or not as
opposed to refine it to a way that's
going to focus and concentrate decision
making accuracy but that's a very
interesting question I can of course
research it up and find it out
to Leslie Rihanna
yeah so I think it's just worth noting
that that's a major issue and that's why
we're recommending and where we are
working together as a region
um there are many different bits of data
involved and that's I guess the thing
that I really want to flag is even once
we have lidar that is not going to solve
all the problems there is complex
modeling that is going to take time that
then needs to be done and it all needs
to interrelate for example River flood
modeling requires digitization of
historic data at environment Southern it
requires all kinds of additional
scientific input so
um I guess what we're trying to flag is
that this is complex and it's likely to
cost more money and it's going to take
time to get this information final
question before we take a break
otherwise religion to the break
Leslie that's not a question there and
it was a
yes
I'm all for the collection of as much
data as we can collect I mean Lida is
essential to us moving forward
from my point of view history is
littered with seat of the pants a little
knowledge is a dangerous thing
unintended consequences projects that we
can avoid by collecting as much data to
give us the way forward as possible I
think if we don't collect it we are just
going to follow the old pattern of
what looks like a good project but turns
out with lots of unintended consequences
that that do air rum region of the
service and and just on the regional
approach to me it's an absolute
no-brainer
um on this issue it makes perfect sense
to work as a region why would we even
contemplate going alone a shoe like that
that is crossing our regional boundaries
in every way shape and form and with the
data alone being Regional data so it
just it's perfect sense to work as a
region
funny was it a quickie yeah so very
quickly because it's actually supporting
what Lizzy just said because we're on
the same page I mean I'm all for Quality
data as well as researcher but I think
we still have to to build on to that is
to get on on with doing
um doing some here with some action
around everything because otherwise it's
like the houses that we can continue to
want better data around our you know
mortality rates and everything like that
but
that takes time and so it's gonna it's
gonna take a lot of time to get all this
this the data pulled together in quality
data at that
so to me I think we just need to focus
on
the reduction of all the greenhouse type
gases and everything else that we need
to do
climate change thanks pania uh
councilors and guests that's where we're
going to take a break
um we have some guests coming from the
Regional Council to present and we will
be resuming that at a quarter to one so
we will pause the live stream and I'll
adjourn the work
thank you
welcome back uh to this reconvened ltp
Workshop looking at Region and
environment uh particularly to those who
are joining us again on the live stream
uh for the first part of the afternoon
session just a reminder
um actually that no decisions are made
at uh at a workshop the counselors and
representatives are discussing ideas
which will ultimately help to inform
documents it will send out for
consultation then we'll get feedback on
the consultation and then an open
meetings those decisions are made it's
for those who are joining us on the zoom
so we reconvene and uh it's my pleasure
to welcome both Karen Wilson and Lucy
Hicks from environment Southland and uh
Karen's kicking us off first of all with
a look at the New River history welcome
Karen thank you kirikota good afternoon
everyone
um and thank you for inviting me to your
Workshop to talk about New River history
um I am the chief scientist at
environment Southland but I am born and
raised in in Southland so near at
history like many of you is near India
to my heart
so I'm just gonna quickly run through
some of the key indicators that tell us
a bit about the health of the esri the
first being sedimentation
so as I'm sure you'll appreciate if you
get too much sediment going into an S3
that that can smother life and the
history
it can inhibit light getting into the
water and so a little bit's fine but too
much is a bad thing
um and as the side slide shows at a lot
of the monitoring sites in the history
the sedimentation rates are very good
but in the I hope I am in particular
we're seeing sedimentation rates about
10 times more than the guideline value
so just to show you what that actually
looks like for those of you that aren't
getting out into the Estuary regularly
it looks like this
um if you have a look at some of these
photos you'll see that them the
sediment's really black
um and it's quite what we call a noxic
so it's quite stripped out of oxygen so
it'll have that sulfur smell that rotten
egg smell and that basically means that
there's very little oxygen in those
sediments and of course you know macro
invertebrates and snails all those types
of things need oxygen in order to in
order to sustain life so not only is
there too much sediment but that
sediment that we're seeing in there is
um
yeah stripped of oxygen which is not a
great thing
one of the other key indicators that we
look at is macro algae which is another
name for seaweeds
um and so again seaweeds and small
amounts are okay but when you get too
much seaweed in the system uh that can
again smother life in the Estuary and it
also
um when that dies off and and settles
down the the bit of the Estuary and
decomposes again that
decomposition will strip the oxygen out
of sediments as well so it kind of it
fuels in that cycle that I was just
talking about
so this is some photos of macro algae
and the estuary
and you can see that the combination of
macro algae and sediment does not paint
a particularly nice
um here's how macro algae those changed
over time in the history
so this is showing a bit of a Time
series from 2001 through to 2021
and basically the key thing to look for
is sort of those orangey colors and
that's showing where there's just too
much Acro macro algae growing and you
can see once again it's up in that where
I hope I um where we're seeing some
pretty
um adverse effects occurring with macro
algae
and I think if I was to pick one slide
that really probably shows a bit of a
story of the um New River Easter is
probably this one which is around
seagrass now seagrass is something that
we actually want to see in the history
because it provides Refuge areas and
it's also a really important breeding
ground for fish
and also for for birds who like to eat
some of the macron vertebrates that
occur in there
so again this isn't the way I hope I am
where we're seeing some of those
seagrass Meadows essentially disappear
between 2001 and 2021
so I've pulled out this quote from a
recent report that basically sums up the
situation in Europe history
and the authors who do a lot of work
around the country looking at history
Health has said overall the wide
widespread presence are persistent and
untrained
macro algae beards extensive patches of
extreme sediment inoxia Progressive
seagrass losses they all serve as clear
indicators at the capacity of the
Estuary to assimilate nutrient loads is
being dramatically exceeded
the scale of the symptoms that we're
seeing is unprecedented in New Zealand
according to these authors and
emphasizes the urgent need to manage
sediment and nutrient loads to prevent
further adverse impacts
so probably should just qualify this by
saying this is not the whole history but
certainly there are very sensitive areas
particularly up in the waihopai arm and
around daffodil Bay they tend to be
depositional zones and we're seeing some
really um really concerning results
so
it's very short and sweet but uh yeah
and as you all know the history has been
significantly modified over the past 150
years by both urban and rural
development and that is very much
um influencing some of the results that
we're seeing as I just said the um
two the two um
areas that are most I guess that are the
of most concern of I hope I am in deaf
Little Bay
and that we have done some work that
have looked at uh
different causes that are going into the
Estuary and
um we do know that discharges from the
city are a significant contributor
um and that so modeling was done to sort
of look at
um
so I know that one of the the confusing
things is that a lot of nutrient load
and a lot of water comes in from a bit
already arm as well as you've so the
question is kind of how much of that
goes into the estrogen circulates back
up into the whitehopai arm versus how
much is coming in through the waihopai
arm itself or through City discharges
itself so we've done some modeling to
look at those Dynamics
um we've got pretty good information
around the Wastewater but the one area
we don't have really good information
around is uh the closed landfill
so uh last summer some work was done
trying to look at sort of a preliminary
study looking at what some of those
landfill discharges might be going into
the yesterday
and particularly they sampled sediments
around the closed landfill area and and
what some people refer to as Pleasure
Bay that little Inlet that's around that
area
um and so some of the conclusions from
that study sort of showed that there
were definitely elevated levels of
arsenic Mercury nickel copper phosphorus
and zinc
um but that the sediment samples were
below the ones that were taken in the
bay itself were below the human health
guidelines
that they were some of them were above
uh the levels for which you would look
to have for ecological protection
but the problem with the study that was
done was that it was pretty hard to tell
from study that is designed how much of
what we were seeing in that Bay Area was
coming from the Coastland forests coming
in from the East Street into that bay
area so there's still quite a little bit
more work done needing to be done to
better understand some of the Dynamics
just within that sort of why hope I am
area itself
so Karen have you got a a timeline or a
plan on on what that work looks like yes
so environment Southland ICC and uh
Tammy and a number of um agencies are
working together to to pull together I
guess the scope of Works around what the
next study needs to be to to advance
that that research
um
I think that is close to being completed
but I haven't seen the final version yet
and you're not sure when that's likely
to be completed next year I think that
will be subject to funding so it is very
relevant for RTP discussions but I don't
have that information with me
um I don't know if Lucy's aware of that
no matter whether the work is happening
and ideally we'll have the results in
order to
notification for that to the end of the
middle of next year so if we have that
information
for that that would be what we're aiming
for thanks
counselors questions or feedback
Ella just one quick question um
years ago they used to spray the grass
in the history was that the same grass
we're talking about though I think it
was called spartina graphs or was it
just that's a different across again
yeah so that that is a different grass
again so that's an introduced species
because what they sprayed would have
killed everything wouldn't it
um I believe that that shouldn't have
been killing off the seagrass native
set was targeted at spartina only right
Evelyn
um
I'm guessing when you talk to the close
then for what you're talking about
the recently close one as opposed to
Historic when you talk about the local
pie arm
where you're looking at
the results of modified modification
including info and in a landfill
um of an historic nature how much of
that is
um feed by what is coming down
survival fight
alone or what is coming out or do you
think is coming out of
um
other other uh the starches into the
water for example uncontrolled storm
water or those sorts of things
yes so we've done we've done a bit of
work to look at
um at the different contributions of
different sources particularly around
nutrients in the history
um and I guess there's this two ways of
two way two ways of approaching it one
is you basically uh do an accounting
approach which is you just count up all
of the discharges occurring in the
catchment from the farming sector and
everything you know and then look at
those relative contributions and
um which which we have done that has
been reported the problem with that
approach though is that
um I'd say a dairy farm just charging up
at mosman their nutrients can be
attenuated by the time it gets down to
an estuary
so um you know that can be as it moves
down through the oriti river perifytan
and other
um plants can take up those nutrients so
not all discharges I guess are created
equal when it when it comes to having an
impact within the Estuary which is why
we've done this other modeling that I
was talking about to sort of better
understand how
how nutrients and sediments and and salt
water impresses fresh water actually
mixed within the Estuary so that's that
3D modeling that's been done but if
we're talking about
I am
that's more likely to be affected by a
David or Bay it's more likely to be
affected by what comes out of the
original pure Ensemble rather than
um
bearing in mind that I do understand
that as the time goes in and out there
will be mixing and things will be taken
up I'm just really interested in what
happens above what we would think of as
the um Estuary proper which is more into
the upper landfilled
all sorts of words
um where we've modified
um the activity on the land what used to
be water that is now
um become part of the city
infrastructure what is coming off those
sorts of surfaces
as opposed to what actually comes down
the White hawkway River into the
waipukaya
because the White River probably has
some a mixture of both domestic
industrial and farming
flow but there's the hard and off aspect
of the of the land that surrounds it as
well do we know much about that
um we know we know a little bit we know
what's coming down through the river
system because we actually measure that
so we can quantify how much is coming
through the RIT and and we're hoping in
terms of nutrient inputs and then
obviously there are discharges that are
going into the Estuary directly we know
a bit of information about some of them
but not all of them and so we have
um a reasonable handle or some
reasonable estimates around the
Wastewater for instance but not so much
around the coast landfill and not so
much around storm water as well
so um part of doing this modeling was to
sort of look at those Dynamics and
certainly um that mobbing suggested that
um a portion of what's coming out the
oriti does sort of mix within the
Estuary then get pushed up into the Ohio
play arm
but
um there's also quite a lot that
obviously comes down through the
Hopewell arm and those direct discharges
from the city Side are also being pushed
up into do I hope I am as well thank you
Pontiac
I just recalled the meeting from last
year around
the New River E Street and and things
like that I'm just wondering what's
changed around the discharge with from
the wasteful so that's coming up in just
a moment okay
suppose I might just hold my question
there it is it is coming good question
Leslie considering the somewhat Stark
reality of what's been lost in 20 years
what more is there to lose
um I think the concern is is that we'll
see that uh degradation get worse and
we'll see that system kind of uh we'll
call my blip or or change in state
which will mean that uh trying to bring
it back
to a healthy robust uh resilient state
becomes much much harder so these
systems are not linear sort of once they
flip they become very very difficult to
sort of
to to get back what was lost
the other concern is that we will see
this degradation spread as well so
certainly in that intertidal area that's
the concern is is how far that that will
spread so how close to that Tipping
Point are we can you estimate
uh yep I did actually have a slide on
that so I think it's something like 16
of the estuaries considered to be in
that uh really eutrophic state in a very
um you know where we're seeing pretty um
pretty significant severe symptoms
so um yeah it's just how high we want
that percentage to go I guess
it's growing at a couple of percent a
year five percent a year can we estimate
how quickly
uh yep I can I can dig up those numbers
and circulate them after this um after
this but I guess one of the things I
would say just around those numbers is
one of the things we did see is after
2020 if you remember we had that big
flood event and that actually washed out
some of that nuisance macro algae out of
the system so we have actually seen some
improvement in the last couple of years
thanks to those floods but we'll see
those numbers
um start to increase again simply
because that that nutrient tap has not
been turned off and that's what fuels
that growth
thank you
preparing is is dredging uh possibility
not so much for nutrients
right
it's quite concerning to from that
report regarding to people thinking New
Zealand's a green clean country and then
people up north I'd speak to think oh
come down south we've you know your
water's clear and pristine Etc and um
that reports painting a different
picture
so you know we don't want to get to the
stage where
up and down the country now even over in
Australia where you thousands of fish
are floating at the top because they
haven't got the oxygen to live on and
that's so it's probably an important
issue that
definitely need to have a look at but um
part of the question is too have you
looked at
um not so much in the bluff Harbor where
the wharf is but probably to the Green
Point in where we have a lot of sediment
and we've built up a sediment every year
through the um just more
sand Etc being washed up through our
tidal port and any effect
we have on that area as well
so uh yes we do do monitoring and black
and Barbara and
um I don't recall though there being
sedimentation issues certainly not to
this scale that we're seeing here
um sorry I'd have to go back and check
some of the latest results on those
particular areas but
um yeah the two Esters that always tend
to come up as as the of most concern in
Southland throughout history monitoring
program is obviously New River history
and the other one would be um Jacob's
River the two where we're seeing these
these types of processes occurring
I guess I'll come back to you I
apologize because the slide that I saw
about the ICC Trace had treated waste
water discharges not actually part of
the presentation anymore so are you able
to perhaps do you want to put the
question again so really I mean based on
from the meeting from last year and the
discussions held around
addressing some of the issues around the
Sea Bridge from the wasteful into the
history
what's changed to date
yeah
so I can't really comment on
invercargill cities Westward treatment
let's grab someone from
um
we'll come back to that thanks Evelyn
sorry
it's about yesterday
so the imperative to do something that
justifies it being a part of the dreams
outside it's probably quite
um high but on the other hand how much
of it is influenced by what
happens in the city and how much of it
the whole Community the whole area needs
to take ownership of I'm not trying to
I'm not trying to that the absolute
complicity on this at all but I'm
thinking that this is actually a bigger
problem than just the city needing to
change its ways it's a problem that the
community needs to address in terms of
some of these discharges and sediments
and things like that how do we get that
message out
when people think that the Estuary is
just this bit
do you want to grab that microphone
can you hear me is that okay
um so I think that's a really good
question and a lot of your questions
have been kind of straying into what do
we do next and I think that a lot of the
answers that sit in the water plan
change to come and how we work on that
together as a whole Community the whole
of Southland
um obviously the picture of New River
Estuary is less than ideal but the
solutions are not ones that only sit
within um in invercargill City's
boundaries so um the plan change to come
we'll be traversing all of these matters
over the next 15 months 18 months give
or take and it's going to be really
important that we collectively get that
message out about the challenge that
we're facing in terms of the size and
the scale of our water issues so
thanks Tom din pania
[Music]
could have gone for the bike than the
last 20 years
and let me tell you the context of the
question and then you can see because
the population of the city reached a
maximum in the mid-1980s and then began
to fall
um and Phil for the next 20 years or so
began to increase again
um over the last 10 years or so
uh so if it was a direct consequence of
the city being a city you would expect
to see that kind of
you know increasing and perhaps
decreases population increase and
decrease because it was quite a
significant change so so do we have that
data
uh we have some
um I'd say ad hoc data going back
further the um I guess the whole uh the
scientific monitoring program started in
the early 2000s and it was actually one
of the first one of the um first
early starters of this type of
monitoring in the country
um so yeah we don't really have we don't
really have really robust information
um going back beyond what I've shown
Nokia and it goes by 20 years you see
okay okay no but I mean it's a pet if
you don't have that data but I mean just
trying to correlate whether there is
actually a straight cause and effect
between the population of the city
growing and
um because you know there may not be
that's not
pania my question is really
um in support of what Raymond had had
just mentioned around the the bluff area
and it probably being viewed is not as
um critical
is the history itself but I I do have to
say that there has been a change over
the past 10 years in that area
especially
um in the Basin part
we do had been discharged from Russian
reach so I suppose for me I don't want
us to get to this this position
and so therefore I think it'd be really
good to get more information around what
it actually looks like to date
um especially knowing that there is
discharge from the port from Ocean Beach
and the Sands that come up through that
channel and that's a an end so there's
nowhere else for it to run
Espana
any other questions or comments
if not thank you for that
and the quick swap seats and move to
Lucy
foreign
as I was introduced before I'm Lucy
Hicks I'm the general manager for policy
and government reform from environment
Southland and um was invited to come
along and talk to you today about the
regional Coastal plan
um as I've already started talking over
there about one of the other plans I'm
responsible for just thought give you a
quick intro so my team is responsible
for the suite of regional plans that we
have so the water and land plan the air
plan the regional policy statement all
sit within our Gambit but as well as
those existing plans we're also
responsible for grappling with the
implications of new things coming so new
environmental legislation that's coming
at us thick and fast from Wellington
changes to the RM reform and the
resource management act and figuring out
what those implications are and how that
translates into our plan making so I'm
happy to take questions
um as we go through
um but in your hands I can just get
through my slides and then happy to
answer them at the end go you do that
then I've got some questions all good so
um as I said I come to talk about the
regional Coastal plan
I thought it'd be helpful just to set
the scene a little in terms of the
background
so um the our regional Coastal plan is a
first generation plan it's the first
Coastal plan that we've had in Southland
since the RMA became
um so and so it started being drafted in
the 1990s
um and eventually most of it became
operative in 2007 except for some
elements relating to Marine farming but
it was fully made operative in 2013. so
um plan making's got a fairly long
gestation but even by those standards
that's a pretty long burn for a plan to
be being made and then to to become
fully operative
fair to say that it's um it's held up
pretty well but there have been a whole
raft of New pieces of legislation and
new challenges and pressures that we're
now facing in the coastal areas so I'm
going to talk a little about those
um but the one of the um things I just
wanted to point to is we've done lots of
work over the last five years
um on what the scale of change is that
needs to happen to the coastal plan and
it's that that I'll just talk through in
a little bit more detail
just this one
so
um as I mentioned um pieces of
legislation and challenges have moved on
and we've become more aware of
um various challenges one of the key
pieces that's different now than when
the regional Coastal plan became
operative was the introduction of the
first New Zealand Coastal policy
statement so that was introduced in 2010
and since then there's been a raft of
new case law and other decisions that
have been made in terms of how that
should be interpreted one of those
relates to king salmon and still kind of
blows my mind that there needed to be a
Supreme Court case to Define what the
word avoid means but that was what was
the matter before The Supreme Court and
the use of the word avoid in relation to
the coastal policy statement has got an
incredibly High bar our plan does not do
that our plan is out of step with that
new National Direction so one of the key
things that the review of the coastal
plan has been reversing has been how do
we ensure that it is as effective as it
needs to be we've taken a raft of public
and stakeholder feedback on the gaps of
the current plan and all of those have
fed into a number of Assessments that
have identified those topics for review
so I've got two slides of what those
topics are and there's some that I
haven't included but um I've just run
you through some of the big ones so as I
mentioned the New Zealand Coastal policy
statement is one of those significant
pieces of new National Direction it
um requires us to take a precautionary
approach our plan does not do that it is
more permissive rather than
precautionary and it is more descriptive
rather than directive so it needs
strengthening is the short version of
that there's a significant amount that
we know now about Coastal hazards recent
history included that the coastal plan
doesn't currently provide protection for
that needs
um stepping up we know that about the
presence of the juvenile toheroa on
ariti and the need for us to take some
actions around protecting those we know
that and Karen's already alluded to some
of the um information that we have that
shows just how our water quality and our
Coastal ecosystems are declining we also
have issues around fjordland significant
issues around fjordland and Bluff as
well in the harbor there in terms of our
anchorages and how those are being
inserted and not um not necessarily
adhering to what's required within the
plan we know that there is significant
pressures in Milford in regards to the
impact of Tourism there and obviously
you'll be aware of the Milford
opportunities program that was um came
up with its master plan in terms of how
we might make some changes in Milford
our Rima is broadly on the water but we
were party too and continue to be
involved in that project
and the final point on those around
carrying capacity so
um this is where the king salmon case is
really important for us
um King Salmon was obviously around an
aquaculture
um case and related to the installation
of aquaculture in areas where there is
outstanding
um natural character or landscapes
those areas are pristine and need to be
protected and the Supreme Court found
the definition of a void was that you
need to avoid the impacts on those areas
and so we need to determine what an
appropriate level of um capacity is for
those areas to ensure that they still
retain those really important
characteristics
so there are a number of other topics
that I've identified
um a while back now 2018 I want to say I
think it was just before I arrived at
environment Southland
um we together commissioned some spatial
studies with yourselves and with
Southern District Council and with Gore
District Council as well
um those were intended to feed into
multiple plan changes and multiple
documents and one of them is the coastal
plan so how we do that and how we work
together with yourselves and with your
marama to apply and make use of the
information that's within those one of
which you would have heard about I'm not
sure if you've already talked about
climate change today but I'm a climate
change study that we did with niwa that
was one of those studies that we
co-commissioned
so I've talked a little bit about
um activity limits so
um we have a discrete plan change going
through at the moment um go to hearing
in June to limit surface water activity
within fjordland
um that was in response to the field of
marine Guardians reflecting to us and
also with monofenowa their concerns
about the lack of limits and not wanting
to wait until the review of the coastal
plan was in place so um but it's a
temporary measure it doesn't fix the
problem so between now and when we
notify the plan change we're going to
have to come up with a bit more of a
nuanced response the plan change is a
fairly blunt tool to prevent any ongoing
intensification we need to make a
strategic and well-informed rounded plan
for aquaculture how we are going to
manage it both now and into the future
we've already talked a bit about the
discharges into coastal areas so again
that's a really key point we need to do
something different with how we're
managing shark cage diving
um there's again new case law around
that and what's allowed or not and we
also are responsible for ensuring that
recreational activities navigational
safety and structures
um are being appropriately protected for
and appropriately provided for so that's
a key one too
so how are we going to advance these
remaining topics
um the review of the coastal plan has
been going on as I said for five years
we have done a number of discussion
papers which have been circulated either
previously some of which with yourselves
before with staff and also with the
likes of the Department of Conservation
and with Theo madama and with Fiona
Marine Guardians and other key
stakeholders to inform the direction
both from the teal monomer board and
from our Council so we have operating
partnership in terms of forming our
policy and so they've given Direction on
a number of matters those are the topics
I've just mentioned are still to be
traversed the aim is to notify the
reviewed Coastal plan late 2024
um there needs to be a significant
amount more public and stakeholder
engagement on a number of topics before
that date
um some of which again I've listed there
the what are we going to do about cruise
ships question but not just cruise ships
there's a significant amount of pressure
both in fueled and Institute island
recura of other kinds of vessels
increase in Expedition size ships that
don't currently have appropriate limits
in place for and we will need to be
talking in more detail with the public
and with yourselves about indigenous
biodiversity through the coast including
how we intend to and need to protect the
toheroa that are honoriti so the
proposed project plan um to get us to
notification is currently in draft and
needs to be confirmed with our new
Council in the next couple of months
um but as soon as that is happening or
as that happens we'll be talking with
yourselves and with staff as well about
which parts we need to talk to you about
in more detail
so with that I'll stop talking to Aaron
thanks Lucy which leads us to that next
slide actually
um it's actually around access to a
ready Beach so what's happening at
environment Southland
um uh with regards to we talked about
and
yeah there is concern around potential
ongoing access to a ready Beach what
happens in the way of consultation with
that
um significant consultation more
consultation is needed we did some um
about three years ago I want to say it
was pre-covered
um the blur of covid uh was
um a very targeted but short
um period of Engagement it gave us some
Intel to then
um test some other thinking but it's no
better near the end of the conversation
we need to have a lot more discussion
with yourselves and with the community
about
um what we found and what is needing to
be protected and how best to do that so
what sort of a timeline are we looking
at Lacey uh probably in the next six
months
um definitely this year and it would be
intended that we would be able to
um discuss exactly what kind of
Engagement might suit you and might suit
the community happy to do that as much
or as little as you'd like so thanks I
mean one of the the issues obviously is
vehicle access and there's been
suggestion of sitting off sitting car
back off the beach because we know we've
had reports of people getting onto and
off the beach sometimes over summer so
is that part of the discussion as well
yeah absolutely need to look at in more
detail where we know those areas of the
juvenile tohara are and we need to frame
up a kind of multi-pronged approach to
how we protect those so some of those
options would include restricting access
not always potentially but we need to
work through what those options might be
can you just clarify for me because the
whole jurisdiction thing from high tide
line
whatever it gets a bit confusing
sometimes who has the final say
over access to oriti beach um Vehicles
so
it's technically a road
which makes it a slightly complicated
question to answer in terms of
restricting access
for protection of the toheroa they are
in the Coastal Marine area so therefore
that's our responsibility but the how we
do that would be shared responsibility
and so it's that why it's really
important for us to work it through
together
could I actually just ask the same
question you did again because when you
said it shared accountability I'm not
clear if that means who is accountable
for determining whose authority with
respect to access to already Beach so
the Regional Council can restrict access
to the beach on the basis that the
tohara needs to be protected but we
don't have the powers to close the road
so it's that part that um is why there's
joint jurisdiction in terms of who's
responsible for which different pieces
okay thanks chair
um council's website states that sea
level rise is at 10 mL a year now
looking everyone seems to be used in the
year 2050 as a sort of a Target so we're
looking at just shy of a foot sea level
increase
and if you look at a ready Beach it's a
very
um
shallow gradient Beach so if you have a
mean sea level rise of a foot
that that that will advance severely
into uh the height of the beach and at
high tide I imagine could be close to
touching the sand dunes now
you look at the environment of the Torah
uh uh what what is environment Southland
doing
to Future forecasts it's it's this
environment that's it's going to be
faced with I mean it's going to be we
won't be worried about access to the
beach because the beach is going to be
uh 2050 it's going to be pretty flooded
um if that gradient I mean it's not as
shallow as to hunanui but uh but Nelson
but you know really it is a it's a
beautiful beach it just goes forever so
what modeling has environment Southland
done because this is you don't need
lidar to protect this
um you've got a foot a rise and you know
how the height of the beach so what's
going to happen
in regards to the population of tohero
yeah the population of other places
what's What's it gonna do it's going to
drive the toroa further up the beach
towards the Sand Dune or what's going to
happen so my understanding and I'm not a
tohara specialist in terms of their
ecology and how they move but they are
highly mobile the sand dunes and and the
lower reaches of the sand dunes are
specifically highly risky that's where
they're smallest and therefore um most
vulnerable
um it is one of the only populations I
think there's two populations in New
Zealand of the Torah and so that's the
reason why the Rarity of them requires
protection in terms of modeling sea
level rise again back to my what we were
saying before about the joint studies
the climate change niwa study shows some
elements of sea level rise numbers
um and also we need to do more of that
to find out exactly how it's going to
affect infrastructure as well as toheroa
so the two things can't be looked at
separately and in terms of what the
climate change implications are but from
a toharoa perspective
I'm not sure okay so how about we just
go straight to the access to the beach
with the sea level rise will it will it
be critical
you know you must realize how high you
must have knowledge already of where the
tideline is going to be in 30 years time
yes but our primary issue isn't whether
or not people can continue to drive on a
really beach in terms of sea level rise
but will it be a factor I'm just saying
that you know obviously the beach will
not be the same
and the toll road are going to be in
different places so what we're we should
be deciding for the future not for the
now
absolutely the coastal plan has to plan
for the fifth year how Horizon so we
would be we need to be taking account
we're still risk
risk sea level rise is obviously one of
those yeah so I guess that's where that
joint responsibility thing comes into
environment Southland are concerned
around the preservation of tokeroa and
our concern is more from the road
perspective and being able to continue a
road which might not be
might not be a road might be more of a
wharf maybe even now
that that's I think that's the
delineating point Tom
I think the
broader question not only but already
but some of the other things that you've
put up there is how do you balance
amenity value
or economic value against the things
that you're describing and and so that
when you look at a ready Beach it is you
know was Queen's Park in my view the the
maybe the second or the first greatest
Outdoor Experience that you know that
people can have here live down here
um
the single cruise ships and and Milford
I I know that there is a
wish I think in some places too
you sat completely but there's a quarter
of a million people come to particularly
to Dunedin every year
um tourists to spend their money who
then get on a cruise ship and go to
Milford if if they were not able again
in Milford they would not come eat
Dunedin
there needs to be a balance on these
things and I just wondered how that
balance has arrived up because it does
seem to meet it quite properly
um the the role that the regional
Authority have is to think about a
particular aspect of it so you know
protecting young Terror attacks a much
higher value than you know my ability of
what my dog in the beach because they
don't have to think about that we do
um so I'm just wondering how these
things are are balanced because clearly
there has to be a bonus otherwise nobody
will ever put a foot in the beach
anywhere no boat would ever be put out
in the water nobody would ever drive a
car again right so there needs to be a
balance so it's a it's a process I'm
asking about about how that balance is
struck
[Laughter]
um I can answer the process question
um and it's a fairly um dull answer to a
really important question I'm afraid so
the resource management mandates that
before we Implement any rules or
policies we have to articulate the
implications of those and we have to do
an assessment which is called a section
32 assessment which balances cultural
economic social and environmental
Provisions so the short version of that
is you can't make decisions that balance
that put one above the other you have to
show that the policies and rules that
you implement has taken account of all
four of those things and what's the most
efficient effective and appropriate way
to protect what needs protecting without
those other pillars kind of falling down
so um yeah it's an RMA mandate that we
do that and how we do that is mandated
within the RMA under the section 32
assessment so
um it's what takes Karen and me lots of
time and our team's lots of time so Ray
then Evelyn
uh Tom I think you answered part of my
question but um
I know a down and Bluff for instance um
it's quite a serious issue of water
quality and um aquaculture that's
potentially going to take place there
and probably to a certain degree some
cruise ships as well
I was in Littleton recently and they had
70 cruise ships for the year and next
year's predicting about 140 double that
number so potential is further down
south those Cruise Ships coming down
not so many in Bluff there's just the
smaller ones but going to Stewart Island
and up to Milford sounds you know it's
going to generate a lot of income but
also at that same point put a lot of
environmental issues in place as well so
they're going to be looked at and um
also around agriculture around um favo
straight um these are like you said the
king salmon there's a number of
companies are looking at the year around
Stuart Island probably from
landowners over around ruapuke Island as
well and there's going to be the issues
around
um the sustainable and what effect it's
going to have on the um
bird life sea life around that area we
also it's important
stuff that you're putting forward that
um you know once it's from place we can
review it and um because
um we're all for it but there's there's
a there's a side of it where that's got
to be a balance so that we who live in
Bluff or people who go out to sea and
Bluff with the recreational or or
fish in the sea for their living you
know they know it's going to be
sustainable when that water quality is
going to be
you know at the highest level possible
at all times
Evelyn
yes so I have been known to wax lyrical
about this before
um the fact that already Beach is
considered to be a road
um pains me considerably the fact that
we are even talking about
um the potential sacrifice of what is a
tonga species under the NATO who claimed
Settlement Act 1998 that it is
um one of only three locations in the
country where tohiroa are there it's I
think the only location where it's
currently fished I could be wrong about
that but I know it's fished under the
um customary Fisheries regulations
South Island
1999.
um however
I think that the issue is that we are
going to have to bring the community
Along on this journey to understand that
what they've been used to be doing
is probably not going to be possible for
much longer and that is going to include
things
as unpalatable as it might seem like the
Burt Monroe
the the fact that the beach itself
nature takes
its natural course
are going to have that discussion and we
will just see the result
because I don't believe that long term
what
people currently enjoy
at audioti beach
is going to be there and I don't
actually think things that this Council
or environment South and do will make a
great deal of difference to that because
beaches are shaped by the action into
action and interaction between
who wear the Sea and the land interface
what we need to be looking at is
for as long as we can have access to
those species is it a really good idea
to have a public road on a beach it's
not all that common
you know
if you go other places you have to park
somewhere to go to the beach
now how we would do that I don't know
but in terms of the shellfish absolutely
there are things that we could do to
minimize our impact on that in the
current
state of how the beach is are people
prepared to do that or do they not think
that toheroi are that important now
they're very important to us they're
part of our heritage but
the other the other part of it is it's
go we're at risk of losing it anyway
what other things can we do what other
things should we do and as Road access
continued Road access and the use of it
for some of the things that we currently
use it for is that wise and sustainable
for the future
Ellen
um yeah we've got a question um but
leading on from we've got what Evelyn's
saying there is
um we all know that uh Torah were
actually introduced to oriki beach
approximately 100 years ago
um and they've survived and prolificated
well they came originally from um
or a bookie there is there any thought
of actually taking them some primary
Beach and
putting them into another beach in
another place that's perhaps a little
bit more
isolated if you like from
uh from communities I mean is that a
thought is there any thought in that
respect because they obviously do move
well and they kept or they can be moved
and they can survive and they can
prolificate
um because that's already happened is
there any thought to that
we couldn't
think about how we could it's happened
before 100 years ago so I just I can't
say why wouldn't be a possibility
I haven't seen that data but that's a
fact
trusted
oh just basically on the other hand
Evelyn I'm thinking about these pillars
the amenities being part of it
and also the idea of being I was
thinking are they possible to move the
Torah which you've just raised I think
we need to look at obviously we've got
to balance the risks with the amenities
as well so while we may lose the road
eventually it is one of the amenities of
this area
yeah I guess the road goes when the
tides up
[Music]
permanently it's actually already
occasionally is up there of course as we
know yeah yeah as a starting point
I think one of the things I just add in
terms of the road consideration
um when we did do the Fairly narrow and
short-term piece of um public engagement
those few years ago one of the
overriding pieces of feedback that we
got were safety concerns not tohiroa
concerns
um and so when it comes that's one of
the other reasons why this does need to
be a joint approach to how we
um together can figure out what's next
for a ret because people are very
concerned about safety as well as
significant groups concerned about the
toheroa
cool
thank you and thank you for the
discussion and thanks Lucy thank you
Karen for taking the time to come along
and join us this afternoon and answer
our questions
which brings us Russell uh to the
regional public transport plan
good afternoon councilors
this next section is really just about
where our regional public just a bit of
background to our public transport plan
and as the slide highlights it is
actually a document that's prepared
um
by the invercargill city council for all
of Southland so we hold the delegation
from environment Southland
um
it lasts for 10 years
I guess the intention of it is and it
describes the services that we
operate and how they operate within our
environment so
slide please for in it this really just
highlights the sorts of activities that
we do and covers our bus services which
includes both the bus Mark which are the
ones that go in and out of the city and
our school in our school buses that we
provide it also covers the Total
Mobility scheme which is probably a
little bit less well known in the
community where we subsidize travel for
those people who can't get to or meet
the criteria for Total Mobility we
certainly have seen a decrease in the
number of people using our buses over a
period of time and we have made a number
of adjustments over the years to try to
correct that
but invercargill seems to have a very
strong desire to have cars
and our desire to get people from cars
into other forms of use as and walking
cycling or public transport is something
that I guess we continue to work on
as you'll see on the right hand section
of that there are the residents
um a recent information
um
many don't use Airbus service
but those who do do need it
foreign
please
this is more information that the work
from rhiannon's team and others that
just talks about some of our feedback we
are getting so what they're saying is
that
um
highest ranking came out to continue
what we continue what we're doing so I
guess that's a relatively strong
stronger indication for us to actually
say the sorts of things that we are
doing are actually
um
some respects
some of the investment in cycling and
infrastructure services are things that
wakakotahi continue to support the
country and encourage us and we have
quite a number of cycle lanes and I
guess that's the challenge that how do
we get more people onto bikes would be a
good thing
interestingly the ranking of um number
three there came out to do with the uh
free travel the government has had
initiative since post covered where we
have half the price of buses from a huge
two dollars per trip to one dollar per
trip and I'm not 100 sure in my mind
whether if we had actually made it free
weather we'd make that much difference
because elsewhere you'll find that cost
isn't necessarily the driver that makes
people change their mind so
um we certainly have nice lots of
parking nice and close to the city where
lots of people travel so I guess there's
no disincentive to actually uh not to
bring your car
um on-demand services are things that
are a little bit uh I guess an emerging
that's where some councils are using
rather than necessarily a scheduled
service it's more of a
um you call up
record that you want to have a trip and
they uh tell you where to walk to and
the bus will pick you up at a certain
time it's an emerging service that tries
to be much more focused so
thanks Brianna
and that very brief overrun leads us to
I guess a number of questions that I
think would be a useful conversation
about Council retains this delegation
from environment Southland
and has done so since 2002 and I guess
the question being are we
placed as the in today's world the right
place to still run the regional public
transport service most
other councils there are a couple who
have the Regional Council running this
service so I guess that's the question
that I posing just to test for us to
work forward
um
and the other questions I thought would
be a useful conversation
would be around
um
if we extended services how they paid
for because that's a that's probably a
really key issue
electrification of the bus fleet is a
requirement as you go beyond 2025 under
the new bus standard so as we get
further in hopefully some of the buses
will become much more cost effective
because at the moment there are
significantly more than the current bus
fleet cost
and I guess the passion or understanding
of what other information we can bring
to talk about demand Services as we
progress through with new contracts so
happy to answer any questions thanks
Russell so with that delegation
from environment South and being a
10-year one and we're two years into the
current one if we were going to if if
Council changed its position how much
notification are we were required to
give because it obviously couldn't take
place until before 2031.
to perhaps clarify the the regional
public transport plan is a 10-year plan
the delegation is a permanent delegation
until such time as we release it and
we've had it since
2002 and my understanding is we have to
give 12 months notice
so when we last took the regional plan
out for consultation some of the
submissions that we received looked at
extensions of services to the likes of
um Winton
um
it's been a hot subject here about bus
access to Bluff that's obviously still a
city thing but the Winton thing tends to
indicate it that's more
Regional than than the city's concern
um
were there any other emerging trends
that came through from those submissions
to the plane last time
nothing particularly in that direction
but has been I guess ongoing
conversations at various time where Gore
has looked at Services between Gore and
matara and that's one of the challenges
that um
that the local authorities to have at
the moment that if
um a local Authority wanted a service in
the area they would need to determine
how they would fund it so we I guess it
wouldn't be any different than if
environments out some held the
delegation and rated for it then they
would also need to decide where the
money would come from to pay the service
and they would need to decide whether it
was a regional activity or whether it
would be based on the the community that
gains the greatest benefit so
ringy thanks chair you raise a question
I I don't know this one um South
District Council do they do their own
transport or
that we manage this for the whole of
South
at the moment there are no services that
currently delivered in in the South
industry I didn't realize the only other
and I guess that's part of the the
reason why it came to us was at the time
we were the best place to we were the
exactly I'd be really Keen to look at
the option um with an open mind of of
handing it back so from the regional
perspective the only thing we're really
managing is the mobility
correct because that's the stuff that
happens outside of our borders there is
no
public transport as such
outside of invercargill City
at this point and the reason I ask that
is if you if we are keen on this carbon
carbon footprint thing
um
obviously more people traveling and an
electrified bus
is more more efficient than a whole lot
of cars moving and from a regional point
of view
it makes sense and the best person to do
that would be the Regional Council
with my tongue and my cheek ringing I'm
going to say that that you were talking
about EVS earlier on with a completely
different twist hey look I'm in a
position where I can just swing open
mind
as I say it was it was a tongue-in-cheek
comment Aaron
station and we haven't spoken about this
self with our colleagues at environment
Southland yet
um but I I don't think that this is
necessarily restricted to a environment
Southland or an ICC position
um what I guess I'd encourage us to do
is think out of the box around who is
best placed to actually run public
transport services for a city and to do
that public transport planning and what
I would tend to say is that us and
environments Southland both doing it
just in our one little part of the city
of the World perhaps doesn't make us
best placed to be doing that are there
others that are running much bigger
networks that potentially we should be
looking to for assistance where we could
contract them in to assist us with those
sorts of services one of the things that
we've really struggled with is employing
people in this space
um we you know made some changes to the
team team a prop just over 12 months ago
with a dedicated public transport
position within the team that we haven't
been able to fill we've been out several
times to the market but people who are
public transport experts don't tend to
live in Southland so I guess I'd just
encourage us to think a little bit more
broadly about it rather than it
necessarily being an esicc issue so Erin
can I clarify you you suggesting one of
the options that we consider as a
network system management process
similar to what PowerNet does with
electricity loans so
and you know I
wanted and I haven't done this yet but
do we approach somebody like ecan and
say you know you guys are operating
services for an extensive number of
local authorities would you provide a
service on contract to ICC slash
environment cell fund as well
um a whole range of different potential
issues not saying one's right or what's
what's wrong I'm just saying there's
potentially a whole range of different
ways that we could explore this
Barry
yeah has there been in any consultation
with the bluff Community about getting
transport for them to come back and and
then back to town
um nothing nothing since the last
conversations we had with Council there
has been in the past and there has been
a number of Trials through through Bluff
but nothing of recent directly
Ria Dean Allen and can I just um take us
back a second with your recommendation
that we need to think outside the square
basically and think more broad about
ideas about how we manage our public
transport
hasn't there been a situation in the
past where we did that very thing and
then found ourselves in a situation
where we had to come and bring it back
to being managed from a South and
invercargill base I'm just my mind's
going to a certain area where we went
out to Market contractors come and ran
the service and I'm talking about in the
80s 90s
back and then we be talking about the
buses rear
is to a system process
as to why in the end that didn't work it
was to return back
no it was I believed in government I
believe when in in around 89 when the
local government reform
um environment South and did run it for
a period of time and and upon some of
the staff leaving at that time the
service was returned to invercargill to
develop it and I guess part of it is
there's two there's two aspects of this
is how you operate the service and I
guess is how you fund you fund Regional
activities I guess is the is the harder
question for if you want to do more
Maria so
um on on your expertise and the role
that you have
and and give them what Aaron's um given
us an idea to go towards what would you
recommend from your experience and to
the council with how to address this
matter
sorry to put you guys on the spot but
um please let me jump in there it's
actually our job I realize that so the
staff will present a variety of options
and we make the decision after I do
realize it yeah I do think that the
question the question that you really
poses this to us there's two aspects how
do we operate the system on a day-to-day
basis but also I think the wide question
is is what services do we want across
the whole of cell phone and how do we
fund it and I think if you actually
separate those two things yes we could
actually contract with I guess a degree
of ease other people rather than
employee staff to deliver the
operational aspect of it which includes
building the plans but the wider
question being is how do you fund some
of the things that we we seek to desire
and if they are necessary I guess that's
that's the rest of that piece and it's
not going to be for invercargill City to
actually rape the southern district for
a service they'll have to decide unless
it's a regional activity and I think
that's the piece that
um the strength where the Regional
Council has
so I guess the question is are you
wanting a paper to come to council with
what options Council has that it could
look at I think so
um just in my view I mean um lumaco bus
service as I'm saying the invercargill
bus service which is included off
obviously um
um it's for air ratepayers so it should
really still be I believe managed by the
cargo city council but I can't
understand
why it appears to be so difficult
because isn't it it's already contracted
to a private company isn't it to run the
service Go Bus they do it would you not
you know and you're talking about you
know
moving into ecan or somewhere like that
wouldn't it be best as to perhaps engage
the uh the actual contractors on a
management scale algorithm suggestions
this would be like a buses to go and
then they actually
do the whole thing was we basically just
provide funding now we and I think we
should also relinquish ourselves of the
responsibility of the districts in Gore
obviously because it's they're not a
thing it should be their District
Council should do the district and go
should do Gora Matera
um so I'll address the first piece of
that
um the the main issue that we have is
that um yes you're absolutely right
there's currently a contract in place
but contracts don't last forever
um that contract is up in the middle of
next year
um every time that we have one of these
maintenance contracts which are quite
long-term things that that come up and
expire there's a significant amount of
work that goes back into reviewing the
contract deciding whether what we have
at the moment is fit for purpose should
we change it how do we change it
rewriting the contract running the
tender process selecting the appropriate
people
um and the challenge that we have at the
moment is we don't have anybody with
expertise within the business apart from
perhaps Russell
um to be able to to actually do that for
us
and as for your question around what the
district wants again the only staff that
we're providing are Total Mobility
vouchers to people in those areas if
Gore wanted a bus transport system they
would have to come and talk to us we
might say you can sort your own one out
but that's a discussion that would
happen later on around actual transport
as opposed to Total Mobility subsidies
okay the contract negotiation now just
if we add on to the supplementary
um
does it have to be that complicated
to go out to Tinder I mean if you've got
a current
contract that is
sufficient like it's working well would
it not just take one person a lawyer or
whatever to from the council to go to
it's public money Ellen so every now and
then the process dictates that it must
go out to Tender so we've got our
obviously our own procurement and
sourcing rules that we we follow we're
also guided although not bound by a
central government's procurement policy
the key one here though is that it's not
just our money it's also money funded by
Waka katahi which means that any use of
that money also has to comply with their
procurement requirements as well
right
um oh yes just regarding to you know
we've had discussion and Bluff around
the bus service and um
probably feel it's quite in vital but
the fact of the matter we've tried it in
the past and
because it's sort of basically profit
driven it's sort of Fallen apart and um
any bus service from Bluffton to Cargill
would say have to be subsidized in some
respect and
as as bus services around invercargill
you know it's it's a service for the
community
and bus services I believe don't make
money it's simple as that but you know
and and if you go and look at the
overall growth strategy of invercargill
even Bluff
it's about the level of service that you
provide to attract that attracts people
to your community
so um
we even had discussions around about
maybe an on-demand service it's um
because there's a lot of
retirees are living in Bluff that can't
get invercargill for um hospital visits
or specialist visits and it's how to
work and with that part of the community
the older ones and and the people who
haven't actually got transport at all to
get them to Cargo how to work in and um
provide that service to them as well
Russell can you just explain perhaps a
little more about that wakakotahi
subsidy and how that works
I was just looking at the time actually
subsidized services that they think are
I guess and they have done so for
invercargill for a for an extended
period of time
once you start getting
um you have to follow a whole range of
rules and I guess that's the the piece
that's just harder than having a
contract with the contractor because we
we have quite a range of reporting and
other requirements so at the moment
we have a range of subsidies depending
on one of each of the activities so for
instance for instance we have a 60
subsidy on the cost of the contract with
the bus service but we also we then have
a 50 subsidy on some of the other
elements so the whole range of funding
but typically at the moment
yeah yeah
recovery looks like the total cost of
the service is then subsidized and we
also get a fear box which comes off the
total cost so if we get if it cost us a
million dollars in a year and we get 150
000 in fearbox therefore there'd be
eight hundred and fifty thousand dollars
that would be the shared cost and then
we would multiply it by a percentage so
moment we would seek to have a fearbox
recovery which is how much you get over
get paid in through the door for every
trip which is probably a third so
effectively we subsidize all of our bus
services by a factor of at least
two-thirds and it's probably higher post
covert
so if we're charging a three if we had
to say for instance if we had a three
dollar fear
on at the door which answers only to it
so I've had a two dollar fear at the
moment we're probably costing us between
six and seven dollars for every person
that travels so
that's that's the economics and a
um I guess a provincial bus service
whereas Auckland has quite a different
service where it has congestioned and it
has high demands and their buses are
full so
and I guess that the issue will be for
for Council
um to to what extent doesn't want to
subsidize above what uh waka kotahi
provides but that's that's a discussion
for the future I think there's
recognition that
perhaps the the transport options for
Bluff certainly need to be examined
hey Mr chair there's certainly I guess
that is the question it's not how we do
it that's reasonably easy it's how you
actually pay for it it's the challenge
and the benefits you get for it and
whether or not your service can meet the
criteria to actually attract a subsidy
Leslie then Trish thanks Mr chair um
listening to this it's probably just as
well Gore in the Southland District have
never asked that have never approached
us to um start public bus services in
their areas
um and I I know about the the disability
scheme um and the fact that we
administer it for the whole region and
that really is the only
Regional part of this otherwise what we
took on from environment settlement was
solely running in invercargill city bus
service
um if there was to be a paper on
alternative options
one of the things I'd be most interested
in
in seeing in such a paper would be what
was the advantage to us
considering that it is solely going to
be an invercargill
city bus service
in the
um disability scheme what would be the
advantage to us and what would be the
cost to us
of even considering a contract with
someone like ecan would it actually be
more expensive to do that considering
that we would be asking
an organization like that to take on a
far distant and small
service and comparative terms
um
yeah and considering when did you say
the contractors up for negotiations
2024 it's going to be and so if we were
going to look at options of anything
else than what we currently have we'd
have to have a paper relatively quickly
otherwise we've got a contract
negotiation that
hits to hit them
all of their contracts will have an
ability to expand or decrease services
over the period of the term anyway so
just reiterate that each game was used
as a hypothetical yeah I'm just thinking
if not
if not same
the same issue of would it be actually
more expensive simply because we would
be asking another organization to take
on a very small
part of an operation
um I I would we'd have to look into that
but I think what what we need to be
realistic about is that this is probably
going to get more expensive either way
um because if we don't have staff
members to do it then we're having to
employ a consultant or somebody like
that to come in and do it obviously not
our preference but if we simply can't
find the staff member
um we're not left with too many choices
in that space yes I suppose that's what
I'm saying there is going to be a paper
it needs to accept those so high level
paper would point out what options would
be considered in the costs of going and
doing a more detailed paper Trish thank
you for your patience that's all right
I'm sort of sitting here thinking must
be other ways
I'm wondering whether people would pay
more even those who can't afford a lot
but would pay more for a service that
was purposeful that was more on a demand
type process you know like if people
from Bluff knew that they could get a
money bus or whatever however it works
if it was if it was more
targeted to the to the people who use it
perhaps that would work and also the
fact that if we're trying to develop
apartment type living or more
intensified living we really want to
discourage cars as well in the center
and so surely an effective bus system
that would support that so they almost
go together
but I definitely would like us to
consider I mean I'm sure you you sort of
you know all the things I don't but you
know an on-demand one that was perhaps
more suitable for the need
would be worth looking at
Uber it's one of the options that can be
Uber yeah yeah there are on-demand
options now yeah
and we've got to be careful about
undercutting private business and again
it comes back to that that Balancing Act
rare you're about to burst I'm just
um wanting to ask a very interesting
question
um hopefully it's okay
out of counselors which however catch
the bus interviews the bus regularly
two you
no no obviously
the the reason why I asked that is it's
we are the car people
um driving in around town so I guess
it's about Russell's indicated
um there's not a willingness for our
public to shift their behavior in taking
their cars to town so I guess on top of
all of that is also a very strong
educational
environmental learnings that we need to
teach in
move together in a community within so
it's kind of like that
that had to do we must change what we're
doing
who's going to pay for it and how we're
going to do it so that it would require
a massive cultural shift yes uh which
would be prompted by a number of things
the lack of availability of private
vehicles of fossil fuel burners were
knocked off the roads
um
Park and Ride options there's a whole
lot of things peak oil is going to
create an issue and as the price point
goes up that might force people to
reassess their desire to park
immediately outside the shop that they
want to go to which they've done for
years because the weather's a bit craddy
from time to time which it is
but at the same time we're talking about
the regional public transport planes
we've seen a tremendous shift over the
last 20 years or longer certainly when I
got here there weren't the same number
of people riding bikes around the city
that we see now and I never thought I'd
see that given the occasional cell
Worcester
um but there's been a shift and one of
the things that we have to consider now
are the cycle lanes that we have and the
rights of the cyclist there are some
nice brightly new painted cycle lanes
that show the priority that cyclists
give in shifting to the middle of an
intersection on on two lane stretches of
Road there are still some parts of our
roading Network though where I wouldn't
ride my bike
streak roundabout being one of them once
you get it once you get over to the
other side and towards the overbridge
you're set but you know it's it's take a
deep breath before you get to that point
so those are all things that that are
discussed Ellen no I have to honestly
say I disagree with you here Mr chairman
that um oh yeah it's a person who drives
the city daily
well I don't know how many kilometers I
do I do many many thousands of
kilometers a year I have yet to see
those cyclists that you're talking about
well that's right now the only people I
see are the people dressed in Lycra who
are riding a bike for a purpose of
Health as opposed to uh just basic
transport maybe we're on the roads at
different times
Tom and then Evelyn
thanks I just feel as though we're
trying to sell a product for which there
is no demand or at least on a very
specialist
demanding and I think that specialist
demand does have to be satisfied so you
know the disabled people who can't
afford to have cars or whatever you know
who and I and I think we better to try
to satisfy that through a targeted
system very much been very conscious to
the point you correctly made shared
about well there are already people who
do that and we are not in a business
that competing with taxis and so forth
but nevertheless I think a generalized
you know Hotpoint Hop Off type bus
service for the city I think what people
are saying is that they don't really
want it I think that's the same at the
moment
um but so I would rather see um I I
would personally rather see us
developing a
um
you know a more specialist service for
people maybe based with many buses or
something of that sort I mean I think we
clearly if we step back far enough we'd
say strategically you know climate
change we want to get people out of the
cars but um you know that may be a
generation before that happens and at
the moment the bus isn't empty and Peter
and the money that we spend on buses may
be better spent and other things those
are the interesting things that will
come up with the electrification and if
we're replacing the bus fleet with
perhaps smaller electric vehicles then
you get a more full vehicle Russell
would you like to respond to Tom's point
my understanding of of the response from
the customers is that we have reasonably
strong support for the bus service
the bus the bus services often used by
those people who don't have other
options and I think that's the key thing
if we actually didn't you know one of
the things when I started to become
involved in buses that
came through my mind is how can you call
it what sort of city would we be if we
didn't actually have a bus service for
those people who couldn't walk who don't
have a car or don't have an access to a
car how do you get somewhere and you
can't afford to be to catch it yeah you
did a 40-seater bus if you've got two or
three people you can put in a minibus
and put in a you know in a car so so one
of the things that we have
um changed in our bus services that we
have 23 Cedar buses now so that we can
size them appropriately and I think
that's where the next wave is I think
on-demand Services is has a future but
you have to work towards it and you have
to understand how it works typically the
on-demand service actually costs the
customer more than a scheduled service
the services are only really viable for
the city to go forward as where they
meet the criteria from wakakotahi to
meet us at a subsidized service so we
just have to meet those meet those
scheduled type compliant sets of rules
Islam
yes well as the only
person sitting at this table that
catches the bus more often than I do
anything else
um I think for me what I would reflect
is that
a pro a price shock like we experienced
in the early 1970s which led to the
careless days legislation
um probably
um whilst might not ever happen again
because we're a bit into Authority or in
these days but
um actually force people to address the
idea that you couldn't just always take
your car whenever you wanted to and that
carpooling and or you know all those
sorts of things was a much better offer
option we've gotten very self-centered I
think as a as a population
all to go wherever I want to and I'll go
when I want to and all that sort of
thing I plan my life around being able
to
um
take public transport if I can if I take
it have to take a taxi it's because I'm
running late for something or I've got
something that is very short notice
things I I do think that it is a
re-education thing I think it's also you
know what size Vehicles we use and
what's the regularity with which they
run all those things that Russell knows
and could recite to us probably in his
sleep but as a community if we want to
continue to have the means
for people to have access to a bus
service we are going to have to make a
commitment to it and then make it
attractive to people to ride
um
I see the same people regularly and I
don't know how they would manage if they
had to pay even at the reduced rate of a
disability rate if they had to pay for a
taxi or a similar service because I
think that whilst it is cheaper it is
not inexpensive and for a lot of people
it would really limit their social
interaction and I think that that is
something that you need to consider it
means it limits where you can shop it
limits where you can go to your GP or
any of those Services if you always have
to take a taxi to get into town
particularly if you're not particularly
physically mobile
I mean I can walk into town and I can
walk home
as long as I don't care too much but
that is not necessarily the case for a
lot of the people who use our bus
service so I'm a bus Advocate but I do
think that it's for Mr Pearson to bring
back the appropriate paper to us for the
next stage of everything not for us to
invent
on the Fly thanks Evelyn and look I need
to wind up a rare you young thing I'll
explain careless days to you later uh
[Laughter]
I'm very wise and knowledgeable I never
said you weren't final question uh pania
all right Annie can you pull it Michael
sorry I just want to touch on
Thomas said around empty buses and touch
on around the need for those that
actually don't have other forms of
transport
um because when I go back to the bluff
trials you know we had an uptake it was
um
well used at the beginning and then it
sort of dropped off and like anything
when you start dropping off you think
okay we can afford to continue this
service any any further or more because
we've got minimal funding but we now
notice weekly buses that travel around
here nothing changes so I'm just saying
if
if I mean do you like anything there's
peak times in these low times I mean
that would be the service that you that
we would have from Bluff
temper tackle
we finish with the fact that um there
will be a discussion paper coming back
to council first to thresh out the the
variances around public transport a
little further
um thank you for your participation this
is the end of the public part of the
workshop councils there are still a
couple of other issues that we need to
discuss
and before the council meeting resumes
at three o'clock so I thank you for your
attention just for the record I do need
to note that mayor Clark forgot to
forward an apology from Council of
Dermody so
we do have that thank you very much that
ends the public part of the workshop
just reminding you that no decisions
were made we're just providing guidance
towards staff to write by this thanks